Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Und ich werde sicherlich kein großer Fan des Games mehr, soviel kann ich schon gleich sagen,
weil die letzten Tage nicht dabei waren.
Auch wenn es echt gar nicht schlecht lief, muss man ja mal sagen, es waren ein paar richtig
coole Runden dabei.
Moin, der Ostsee Junge, ohne Vettel ist es auch schon 19 Monate richtig, Poggers.
Komm, du hast jetzt den Gold Keks am Start.
Exquisite.
Den Gold Keks, den es übrigens, muss man vielleicht an der Stelle auch mal sagen, den
Gold Keks, den es ohne den Vettel gar nicht gäbe.
Weil er hat den Designer, die Designerin in dem Fall gesucht für die Kekse.
Exquisite, next level shit.
Also Captain Poggers, falls du mitmachen willst, oder hier auch, äh, Moritz, falls du mitmachen
willst, aber ich bezweifle es, ich bezweifle es, bisschen lauter müssen wir glaube ich
schon, weil es Game Sorts zu leise ist.
Welcher Streamer hat denn im Urlaub, ja.
Ich bin aber gespannt.
Also was wir heute auf jeden Fall, heute werden wir definitiv nicht ganz so lange, also wir
spielen wahrscheinlich wieder bis 23 Uhr, aber wir werden heute definitiv nicht die
ganze Zeit nur das Game spielen, wir werden uns auch mal ein paar Sachen noch auf YouTube
angucken.
Zum Beispiel werden wir ein paar Comments lesen unter meinem Video, da sind wieder ein
paar absolut...
Bulle, genau, da sind wieder ein paar absolut haarsträubende Dinger dabei, wo ich mir auch
keine Ahnung...
Gab es schon wieder, gibt jeden Tag, jeden Tag gibt es keinen Patch, der was fixt.
Wir gucken uns ein paar Sachen an, dann noch ein paar andere Videos, wo uns die Leute drüber
aufnehmen müssen.
Wir gucken uns das Video vom Lost an, habe ich nämlich vorhin gesehen, dass der was hochgeladen
hat, woraus er sich ein bisschen drüber ausgekotzt hat, das Problem, jetzt, jetzt fangen sie
alle an.
Ich muss erst mal wieder einen raushauen, jetzt fangen sie alle an, dann habe ich ein
Video gesehen von ihm hier, das kenne ich, das hatte ich schon mal angefangen zu schauen
und ich habe am Anfang rausgehört, er findet das Video eigentlich relativ gut, aber, warum
ich jetzt noch mal weiter gucken will, wobei ich weiß nicht ob die 33 Minuten vielleicht
überspringen sind, anscheinend hat er irgendwie Bezug auf mein Video genommen, zumindest hat
mir das einer geschrieben, ich weiß nicht ob das stimmt, bin ich mal gespannt was er
erzählt und dann gucken wir nochmal eben, nein, nein, das gucken wir nicht nochmal,
ja ihr wisst was ich meine.
Aber jetzt spielen wir erst mal schnell eine Runde, ich trage noch den Cap'n'Foggers ein,
nicht wundern, dass es im Hauptmenü ruckelt, das ist normal, sobald wir in-game sind ruckelt
es nimmer.
Ich muss mal kurz meine Nackenentspannungs-Anti-Kopfübung machen, schon spät, schon alt, ab einem gewissen
Alter muss man das machen, jetzt gehts, alles klar, fuck, weiß ich immer ob ich die Karte
in Battlefield 3 Fullscreen machen kann, du kannst in Battlefield 3 relativ viel in der
Konfig-Datei einstellen, da musst du mal gucken, aus dem Kopf weiß ich das nicht, ja richtig
feels bad.
Wie gesagt ich kann dir das empfehlen, falls du Kopfschmerzen hast und hier so eher Nacken
und sonst was, wenn du einfach die Hände so mal verschränkst, hinter den Kopf nimmst
und dann quasi mit der Rückseite vom Kopf so in die Hände drückst und mit den Händen
dagegen, weiß nicht wie man diese Übung nennt, aber das hilft bei mir immer, tu mal Nacken
tut weh Kopf, oh ja was soll ich denn sagen, so wen haben wir denn sonst noch, will sonst
noch jemand Leute, will sonst noch jemand, seh ich da grad dass der Moritz auch am Start
ist, dann laden wir den auch ein, falls der mitmachen will, stretching mit Max so siehts
aus, nice auf gehts GG Eats, naja Breakthrough, lustigerweise ist Conquest eigentlich der
bessere Modus, aber durch dieses ewig lange rennen ist Breakthrough dann zumindest kurzweiliger.
Ist Day 3 Patch ein Chebathe, he lacks critical information, ja das ist ein Chebathe, das
ist ein Chebathe, weil he doesn't know, ich hab den ersten Tag das gleiche geschrieben,
den zweiten Tag das gleiche geschrieben, schreib ich den dritten Tag halt auch einfach das
gleiche, ich schreib jetzt jeden Tag wo wir Battlefield spielen, Day 4 Patch hat alles
gefixt, Day 5 Patch hat alles gefixt, mal gucken vielleicht kommt ja der Tag wo der Patch
dann wirklich was fixt, stellt euch das mal vor, stellt euch mal vor wir schreiben das
jetzt 240 Tage und am 241 Tag kommt dann der Patch der alles fixt, wobei nächste Woche
kommt ja wirklich ein Patch, aber ob der jetzt so viel behebt, na warte mal ab ok, machen
wir kurz die Musik aus, sag mir mal jetzt ob es laut genug ist, es dürfte nicht ruckeln,
es dürfte nicht ruckeln, es müsste laut genug sein und achso Moment, ah hat mein Battle
für die Auflösung wieder geändert, he jetzt stimmt alles, Booster und Booster, alles klar
oh Gott das ist Discarded, Leute Discarded Breakthrough ich sag's euch, ich muss jetzt
ich muss jetzt, das ist jetzt mein Trick ich hab festgestellt das funktioniert, umso beruhigter
ich spreche, umso weniger rege ich mich nicht auf in dem Spiel, also ich muss hyper, hyper
relaxed, ah yes, ja erstmal ne Runde spotten, spot, spotten, oh oh oh, wow, alter bitte
mehr Beschleunigung aus dem Heli raus wenn es geht, ok wir switchen mal, sag mal, was
zum Teufel ist mit dem, ich hab den Wingsuit gezündet, was ist mit dem Cave Lost wieder,
sag mal, das Game, nice, next please, wir spielen heut mal, ich versuche heut mal mp9 zu spielen,
es kann aber sein, dass wir das nicht lange durchhalten und ppega29 anschauen, sag mal,
kann sich sein, kann das sein, dass wir hier im Stream ppega29 erfunden haben, ich kann
mich nicht dran erinnern, dass es irgendjemand gesagt hatte, bevor ich hier im Stream mit
angefangen hab und ich glaube ich hab im Stream damit angefangen, weil das irgendjemand von
euch gesagt hat, weil ich irgendwie Witze gemacht hab, ppega29 und die Leute haben dann gesagt
mehr ppega29 und jetzt sagt es, jetzt sagen es alle, jetzt sagen sie das alle hier, ganz
gesettet, würde ich sagen, nein, ich brauch die Granate, ja, der Lost sagt es, ich weiß,
der Lost sagt es jetzt auch, ich glaub das hat sich, hallo, ich kann mich nicht mehr selbst
heilen mit dem Shortcut, ah, weil ich voll bin, ok, das wird es natürlich erklären,
schon refer military standards die machen wir natürlich, die naturallyanger Netzwerke,
eh?
ach ne, dachte jetzt, die kommt hier rumgestellt und kriegt dann aus und aus, lebt da noch
Alles klar.
DM7!
GG Eats, gutes Sniper, two hit.
Sieht bei mir das nur so rucklig ausgefühlt, 30-50, meinst du jetzt im Stream oder meinst
du jetzt bei dir im Spiel selbst?
Weil im Stream siehts bei mir eigentlich relativ okay aus.
Ich sehs gerade in der Vorschau also.
Sag mal ist okay, die Vorschau vom zweiten, der Stream wirklich?
Moment das muss ich mal kurz jetzt, kann sein ersterben, ich muss mal kurz auf dem Handy
gucken ob das flüssig ist, weil mein zweiter Rechner ist da nicht die, der zweiten Rechner
ist das nicht Aussage kräftig, wenn ich da gucke live, ne Sekunde, muss ich das mal einschauen,
es kann sein das das aus irgendwelchen Gründen rumbackt, ja gucken wir mal, mal kurz bisschen
im Kreis rennen, ich muss mal auf dem Handy gucken, Achtung ich bin übrigens mitten
im Gegnergebiet was eigentlich witzig ist, so ich muss jetzt auf dem Handy gucken ob
das flüssig ist, falls sich das irgendwann mal einbekommt, nö, das sieht eigentlich
ziemlich gut aus, das sieht eigentlich okay aus, kann man das jetzt beschweren, sag mal
ich lieg hier seit 3 Stunden im Gegnersport und keinem interessiert, wie kann das sein,
warum spottet mich mal wenigstens jemand, wäre es vielleicht möglich dass hier niemand
ist, bling, ich muss sagen den Headshot, den Headshot, doch als schweres Entsatz zu bilden,
der ist tatsächlich relativ gut, also sollte der Streamer noch irgendjemand ruckeln, jetzt
kommen sie, jetzt kommen sie, sollte der Streamer noch irgendjemand ruckeln dann sagt mir
Bescheid, dann mach ich Game Capture, wie er einfach rüber geslided ist, ich wollte
hier überhaupt nicht ruf, guck mal hier ist alles voll, ich kann nicht aim, ADS geht nicht,
was ist hier kaputt, ich kann nicht zoomen, Alter, Aiming Downside war einfach grad Disabled,
ging einfach nicht mehr, war einfach aus, ne passt so weit, okay, lass mich mal in meiner
Vorschau kurz checken, ist da ein Patch gekommen, es ist kein Patch gekommen der was behebt,
okay, ah Mist, ach guck mal wir kriegen A1, oh nice, die sind relativ schwer diese ersten
beiden Bases, finde ich, dementsprechend haben wir vielleicht Glück und können da jetzt
mit rein, ja sehr gut, sehr schön, die sind so flach, seht ihr das, das ist einfach eine
Ebene, wo sie sich gedacht haben wir ja, machen wir einfach mal, machen wir so zwei Container
drauf, das reicht schon, zwei Container und das reicht, das muss ausreichen, wer will
schon mehr als zwei Container, was weird Game, Layout, was, also das ist vieles weird Champ
an dem Game, aber das Layout, nein, nein, nein, habt ihr gesehen die kann Granaten werfen
ohne den Namen zu benutzen, das, ich hab übrigens schon längst geswitcht, aber das Game hat
es nicht mitbekommen, okay, Yolo, jetzt hier, volle Pulle, gib ihm, gib ihm, ne Digger,
gib ihm, sagt man heute so, habe ich mir sagen lassen, aber ich dachte man kann jetzt sie
abheben vielleicht, natürlich, natürlich von der Seite, aber was sonst, was sonst, das
ist ja auch so ein Kritik, also eigentlich wirklich ein riesen Kritikpunkt an dem Game,
den ich hab durch die vielen Spieler, du siehst einen, dich sehen fünf bis fünfzehn,
das ist halt heftig, überall anders wäre man jetzt durchgegangen wie nix, hätten einfach
noch die zwei drei verbleibenden gebashed, okay kein Hit, nice, was es geht um MW3, hast
du mitbekommen, dass am Donnerstag die Closed Beta startet, soll bis März dauern und ab
da soll es in die Open Beta gehen und F2P für die Closed Beta spielen sich quasi, wie MW3,
es kommt doch jetzt erst MW2 in nächstes Jahr Call of Duty, was für ein MW3, das alte
MW3 oder, oder, oder, oder, hä? Ach World War 3, ja das wird doch eh nix, also das Game,
ich hab das ja Early Access gedings damals auf Steam, also das was ich bisher gesehen
habe, hat mich mal überhaupt nicht geschockt, mal gar nicht, oh oh, ey dieses Game, du stehst
da und du bist von allen Seiten weg Gachibast, also ich hab, ich hab das mal gespielt, als
es, als es, als es, Sekunde ich brauch das richtige E-Mode, okay weiter gehts, vielleicht
soll ich einfach wieder auf PP29 switchen, mit PP29 ist alles einfacher, damals hätte
es was werden können, also ich glaube nicht, dass das, ich glaube ehrlich gesagt noch nicht
mal, dass die eineinhalb Jahre da vieler was dran gemacht haben, ich hab vor 2-3 Monaten
so nen Closed Test bisschen geguckt auf Twitch und das Game war im Prinzip noch mehr oder
weniger das gleiche wie zu diesem Closed Test, nur mit dem Unterschied, alter was ist denn
hier los man, the fuck alter, wie willst du denn hier, okay, vielleicht können wir so
nen Hovercraft droppen, können wir so nen Hovercraft, natürlich nicht, vielleicht darf ich sowas
droppen jetzt, oh das ist ja, das ist ja so nice, guck mal, DICE hat sich gedacht, also
hier, das ist wie Harvest Day, nur in schlecht, findet ihr, guck mal, guck mal, das ist ein
bisschen wie Harvest Day, guckt euch mal die Map an so vom Feld her, das ist ein bisschen
wie Harvest Day, nur in schlecht, weil in Harvest Day hat es zu Hügel, also so, so, so,
Tranches, lass mich in Ruhe, ich will Harvest Day erklären, Mensch, pass mal auf, der wird
jetzt pp-gatt, hätte auch funktionieren können, hätte auch funktionieren können, aber man
kanns ja mal probieren, ja Harvest Day hatte so Tranches, hatte rechts den Hügel, hatte
links den, den, den Fluss, hatte dann ein Endkorn mit ein paar unzerstörbaren Teilen
und so, also da muss man schon sagen, Harvest Day war halt durchdacht, aber es hat schon
was von Harvest Day, die Idee war gut, ne, aber das, ja, da sind ja, habt ihrs gesehen,
das Problem war nicht der Typ auf den ich zugeflogen bin, das Problem war, dass in der
Zwischenzeit, glaub fünf Leute oder so, wieder bei dem gespawnt sind, so, wir machen jetzt
den Flank des Jahrhunderts, vielleicht können wir sogar ein bisschen rüberfliegen, aber
wir kommen ja nicht so weit, so, weiter kommen wir nicht, kann ich überall hin gleiten,
ah, da ist ein Hovercraft, krieg ich auch ein Hovercraft, komm gib mir ein Hovercraft,
ah, ich darf B nicht drücken, aber in fünf Sekunden darf ich B drücken, ich bleib jetzt
einfach liegen und dann, ok, warum genau ist B auf dem Cooldown gewesen und ist jetzt deaktiviert?
ah, guck mal, da kommt ein Auto, vielleicht kann ich den Flanken von hinten, oder, parts
der freut sich jetzt, Leute, was will ich denn hier machen, bitte schön, kann mir irgendjemand
erklären, wie ich den Typ, in irgendeiner Art und Weise, was soll ich tun, was willst
du tun, ja, aber, nichts, machst nichts einfach nur, ja, nice, nice, gachi bars in the bobs,
gibs mir von, ja, nice, gut, mach, alles klar, ah, nice, da geh ich jetzt hoch, da geh ich
jetzt hoch und lass mich auf den Weg hoch, Alter, der wird so gebasht, der Dude, man,
ich dachte, das ist ein Gegner, da liegt doch noch einer, oder, ne, der ist down, oder
ist der Typ ganz oben, kann man hier eigentlich auch hoch, ne, ok, ich geb zu, Leute, ich
habe nicht, ich habe nicht die richtige Waffe dafür, die Waffe ist etwas, etwas sackig dafür,
warum gucken die, fuck man, warum gucken die, warum wissen die, dass ich da bin, die wissen
einfach, dass ich am Start bin, obwohl ich hinter ihnen auf dem Kran stehe, gut, wegen
dem Motion Sensor wahrscheinlich, ich habe runter geschossen, ja, und, das sind 50 Milliarden
Punkte, die wissen, dass ich das auf dem Kran bin, ah, nice, die kloppen sich mit dem Auto,
ok, also, ok, ich würde jetzt gerne bei DICE, also so, hallo, DICE Schweden, was soll ich
machen, ich bräuchte einen Coach von DICE, der mir erklärt, was man sich hierbei gedacht
hat, der Söderlund ist doch frei, den haben sie doch rausgeschmissen ab Battlefield 5,
vielleicht kann er, vielleicht hat er noch genug Ahnung davon, wie das, wie das funktioniert,
vielleicht soll ich immer auf Fiverr, wollen wir mal gucken, vielleicht sind hier auf Fiverr
ein paar DICE Developer, die mich coachen können, wie man, wie man hier vorgeht auf
diesen Maps, dass man, dass man hier durchkommt, ich brauch DICE Coaches, anders geht das nicht,
ja, nice, nice, nice, sehr gut, nice, sehr gut, es ist einfach Zucker, ja, nee, es wird
nicht, Royal, es wird nicht dasselbe Theater wie bei Battlefield 4, der Unterschied zwischen
Battlefield 2 und 42 und Battlefield 4 ist, dass du eigentlich von Anfang an erkennen
konntest, dass in Battlefield 4 ein richtig gutes Game steckt, zumindest ich, ich weiß,
da kann man sich drüber streiten, es gibt Leute, die sehen das anders, aber zumindest
ich erkenne das hier nicht, ich weiß nicht, wo er erschießt, mit dem Enterhaken, ich hab
kein Enterhaken, ich hab den Wingsuit dabei, also ich finde fast für diese Map müsste
es einen Mobility-Held geben mit Enterhaken und Wingsuit, ich weiß gar nicht, wo der
ist, wo ist der überhaupt, von wo werde ich überhaupt beschossen, I don't know, DLC
also, okay vielleicht können wir, vielleicht können wir noch ein Stückchen fliegen, die
Leiter ist auch komisch, achja, achja, nice, da ist er, da ist er, obvious, also chat, das
hätte man schon mal predikten können, dass der da jetzt ist, das hätte man wissen müssen,
ich finde das ist eigentlich ziemlich offensichtlich gewesen, ich hab da nicht hingekommen, es
war offensichtlich, dass der da steht, das war einfach zu offensichtlich, so, okay, uns
bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig, als pp 29 zu spielen, seht ihr ja gerade, das ist ja
nicht, was willst du machen, du hast nicht die Red, okay wir haben verloren, Eats predict,
sehr cringe, sehr cringe, ja, richtig cringe, gebe ich dir rechts, ganze Game ist cringe,
die armen Devs, stell dir mal vor das Game, woran du in den letzten Jahren gearbeitet
hast, ist scheiße zum zweiten Mal, also in der Haut der Devs möchte ich wirklich nicht
stecken, weil die kriegen es in der Regel doppelt beschissen ab, die müssen ein Game
machen, worauf sie, also worauf sie eigentlich wahrscheinlich schon fast erwarten, dass
es nicht gut ankommt und am Ende, wenn es nicht gut läuft, werden sie wahrscheinlich
auch noch rausgeschmissen, weil es nicht gut gelaufen ist und jetzt irgendwie Leute entlassen
werden oder sonst was, ja, also das ist, das ist echt dumm, also ich glaube, du kannst
als Projektleiter, Developer, Designer an diesem Spiel eigentlich nur verlieren, also
den, den es als erstes trifft, ist der Wikinger Typ, ich weiß nicht wie er heißt, da der
DICE Projektleiter von diesem Game, der auch immer in den Videos am Start war, der wie
gesagt so straight aus Vikings aussieht, auch vom Bart her und so, wenn ich jetzt sage,
er ist eine Schwede, dann wisst ihr nicht, wen ich meine, weil das sind alles Schweden
und den trifft es wahrscheinlich als erstes, der hat wahrscheinlich die ganze Zeit gesagt,
ja heute das Game ist nicht fertig, das Game wird kacke, das wird schlecht ankommen und
die haben gesagt, nein, nein, das passt schon, wir patchen das alles, na na, mach mal raus,
mach mal raus jetzt, jetzt aber, jetzt muss es aber raus, ja und er ist der Erste, der
jetzt seinen Job verliert, weil das Game nicht gut ist, nein, Votes habe ich nicht gemacht,
müsste man machen, ich habe leider vergessen, wann ich das gesagt habe, ich will jetzt nicht,
ich will jetzt nicht das ganze Wort durchgucken, oh nein, come on, come on, please, erst das
und jetzt Breakaway, Leute wir haben noch einen Slot frei, will noch irgendjemand das Elend
sich mit an, ah der Serious Max ist doch auch da, ok, passt, ist alles voll, ich hab mich
verguckt, gibt es eigentlich wie in der Beta Bots, ja, es gibt Bots, es gibt Bots sogar
theoretisch in drei verschiedenen Schwierigkeitsstufen, doch die Map ist schlechter als die letzte,
du wirst es gleich sehen, kannst du mal einen Jet nehmen, nein, ich fliege keinen Jet, ja
also wie gesagt, die Bots gibt es in drei verschiedenen Schwierigkeitsstufen, ich glaube
Beginner, Intermediate und Advanced und mir ist heute Morgen was aufgefallen, was mit
diesen Bots, also wegen diesen Bots, nämlich, dass man Attachments für die Waffen, ich
überleg gerade, dass man Attachments für die Waffen mit Bots frei spielen kann, ich
hab das heute Morgen ausprobiert, ich hab gedacht, ach Mist, du musst ja noch für die
MP9 die Attachments frei spielen, also was hab ich gemacht, mal versucht Bots, Bot-Match
aufzumachen und hab 120 Kills gemacht, Bots und danach hab ich fast alles mit der MP9
freigeschaltet, das geht, ist die laut oder, oder passt die Lautstärke so, ne passt, passt
glaube ich, oh, oh, oh, nein, nein, nein, ich will keine Cringe, äh, Dings, ich will
den Bashen hier, ich will den Bashen, Alter, merke, es ist immer der, den du nicht siehst
in diesem Battlefield und es ist ganz schrecklich, ok, nice, setz dich, ok, auf, da fahren wir
jetzt hin und klatschen mit der 30mm rein, Alter, gib ihm, gatschi, Bass, ok, ok, ok,
gatschi, Bass, Mann, fuck, aber richtig rein gefahren von hinten, aber das Ding ist übrigens
in Hazard Zone, Abfuck-OP, ich kann sich anders sagen, also ich hab ja vorhin Hazard Zone
gespielt, paar Stunden, ich muss ja morgen noch ein Sponsored Video dazu machen, Painz
Champ, ähm, und wenn du dort ein Auto hast mit diesem 30mm Geschütz, oder noch schlimmer,
du hast zwei Autos mit dem 30mm Geschütz, dann bist du unbesiegbar, Max ist gekauft,
ja, ist so, das ist insofern Confirmed, ich hab's ja selbst gesagt, Alter, lass mich
doch mal in Ruhe hier, ich will doch einfach nur mal da raus gucken, ohne von irgendeinem
Typ gesniped zu werden, richtig cringe das Game, ja, ey, please, krieg ich den Rats
vielleicht, guck mal, da sind so viele Leute, Revive, Request, Help, ach ne, das sind Gegner,
da wird mich jetzt garantiert keiner reviven, morgen kommt das Video, Battlefield, bestes
Game, oh ja, also wenn dieses Video irgendwann mal kommt, dann wahrscheinlich frühestens
in einem Jahr, und dann auch nur, wenn sie komplett die Kurve gekriegt haben, aber komplett,
was ich nicht glaube, aber ich wollte eigentlich, okay, Ende erst, Ha, Kergwe, da sitzt er,
ich wollte gerade sagen im Busch, ne, im Busch sitzt er nicht, im Container sitzt er, hast
den Busch, darfst du in dem Placement, ouch, ach da, darfst du in dem Placement deine eigene
Meinung sagen, ja, darf ich, also ich darf im Prinzip alles sagen, was ich will, aber
sie müssen das Video abnehmen, was im Endeffekt heißt, ja, ich darf alles sagen, was ich will,
ob ich das Video dann zeigen darf, ist wieder was anderes, hallo, hallo, Motion Sensor,
oh no, ja, ey, das ist so, Alter, was ist denn da um die Ecke los, da ist der Bus stehengeblieben
und jetzt sind alle ausgestiegen, guckt euch das mal an, das sind 40 Gegner, hinter diesem
Felsen, jetzt legit Leute, hinter diesem Felsen, stehen mehr als eine komplette Runde, Battlefield
3, Battlefield 4, also alle Battlefields bisher überhaupt Spieler drin hatten, so ist es, wo
sieht es aus, und welcher der Felsen ist es überhaupt gewesen, wo ist der Felsen wo
sind alle stehen, das ist ein Panzer, der Panzmann, schmeißen wir noch mal hier einen Motion Sensor,
vielleicht kriegen wir irgendwas, okay, okay, wir laufen jetzt übers offene Feld, oh ne,
da sind sie schon, uns bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig als übers offene Feld zu laufen,
immer da wo du nicht hin guckst, ja, vielleicht kriege ich noch einen Rats, warte mal, sind
das überhaupt, sind das überhaupt Teammates, help, help, help, Boris, mein Freund Boris,
retz mich, nice, ich find's auch geil, wenn so Sachen wie dieser Crapling Hook einfach
nicht funktionieren, nice, easy win, jetzt gingen wir aber gut durch hier, da kannst
du nichts sagen, hast du richtig verstanden, es gibt kein TDM, nein es gibt kein TDM, du
kannst in Portal TDM spielen, aber es gibt kein All Out Warfare TDM, es gibt in dem
Spiel eigentlich nichts, daran kannst du nicht gewöhnen, also es gibt, ja es gibt nichts,
es gibt zwei Spielmodi und sieben Maps, das war's, also alles was nicht zu diesen zwei
Spielmodi gehört und in sieben Maps, die gibt es nicht, ist nicht vorhanden, guck mal,
der hat nicht PPGar29 gespielt und schon ist er down, oh man, jetzt hab ich hier den, den,
den Five Head Eleven Head Flank gemacht und was ist passiert, nix, hat nicht funktioniert,
da schreit noch einer rum, hier ist doch noch einer oder, warum schreien die noch rum, die
sind doch tot, wie können die noch rumschreien, Alpaclap, oh da drüben, guckt euch mal an,
da drüben geht's rund, oh da unten, guck mal da, was ist denn da unten, oh da drüben,
da drüben, oh fuck man, oh oh oh no, hier ist so viel Deckung, ich glaube ich hätte
mich hier unter diesem Hügel vielleicht verstecken können, hier guck hier so, hier, hier ist
Deckung, seht ihr das, Massive Deckung, jetzt sagt, das sagt mal einer, das Spiel hat keine
Deckung, guck mal hier, also da ist schon verdammt viel Deckung da, da ist schon, da
ist schon, kann man jetzt sagen, dass da keine Deckung gibt, Fake News, Deckung ist vorhanden,
ja das wird dem Mainweapon nicht in die Hand nehmen können, kommt manchmal vor, Achtung,
ich habe hier gar keine Granate, sag mal, wo müssen wir eigentlich hin, ich bin vollkommen
ratlos, wo es eigentlich lang geht, ach da unten, halber Kilometer, halber Kilometer,
auf gehts, Hovercraft, mehr Hovercraft, ich glaube, ich glaube, also es wird mal Zeit für
irgendwie so einen Film, Predator vs Hovercraft oder sowas, ok ich gebe zu, das war jetzt
doch schon, der Witz war äußerst Spirit Champ, aber wenn man zu viel Battlefield 2042 gespielt
hat, dann funktioniert das hier eh nicht mehr richtig, Endchamp, oder wie wärs mit,
wie wärs mit den drei apokalyptischen Hovercrafts, ich hör auf, ich hör auf, ist ok, ist gut,
ich bin ruhig, ich verliere eh die letzten Gehirnzellen, während ich da spiele, kann
das sein, dass hier alles offen ist, dass einfach gar nix an Gegnern am Start ist gerade, es
sieht so aus, guck mal und wir bekommen sogar Muni, ja fall doch mal um, ok alles klar,
das ist nice, gg, bei so einem Magazin kann man schon mal stehen bleiben, 10 Hitmarker
easy, ja die Sache ist, das war ja nicht einer, das waren ja 5 unterschiedliche Gegner, die
ich gehitmarkert habe, aber man kann in diesem Spiel, das ist auch was, was ich sehr fragwürdig
finde, man kann nicht mehr gescheit durch Gegner durchschießen, das finde ich wirklich
doof, grüßt mich nicht, nope, no pass, ok nice, der ist down, oh da kommt ein Panzmann,
weg, Hovercraft, Hovercraft, lasst ihn mich mit, pass auf, ich stells mich jetzt in unser
Hovercraft rein, ich zieh mich da jetzt ran, steig ein und bash alles, oder auch nicht,
und ich guck nach der Runde in Chat, oh, pass zum, pass, gut nice, ich weiß nicht genau
wo er ist, ob er da ist, war er da, sieht alles so gleich aus, nein, hier vielleicht, ok ich
blick da nicht durch, das hat zu gering wiedererkennungswert, Chat sagt, hab das Gefühl BF hat inzwischen
eine alle gewinnt Mentalität, ja, ja, ja, hast du recht, aber ich finde das hatte Battlefield
irgendwie, also zumindest seit Battlefield 3 eigentlich schon, ok, warum genau ist das
jetzt nicht, nehm mich mit, ich finde das hatte Battlefield seit 3 schon mit dem Unterschied,
das ist halt das riesen Ding, dass du halt in Battlefield 3 noch viel rausholen konntest,
aber in Battlefield 3 konnten auch Leute, die schlecht waren, durchaus ihren Spaß haben,
finde ich zumindest, funktioniert hier überhaupt nicht, nix gerade mit irgendwie berghoch
sonst was, klar in Battlefield 3, wenn du reingeschissen hast, das war schon frustrierend,
aber du konntest auch so trotzdem Momente haben, wo du gut abgehst, ja, aber du hast
schon recht, also diesmal haben sie es echt übertrieben, aber ja doch diesmal haben sie
es schon übertrieben, ich mein diesmal, du siehst das ja, dass du keine Squads wechseln
kannst, dass du keinen Scoreboard hast, dass du am Ende der Runde nicht mal angezeigt
bekommst, wer gut und schlecht ist, dass sich keiner gekränkt fühlt, guck mal, könnt ihr
euch gestern an die Runde Breakover erinnern, 70 Kills, irgendwie 70 Kills, 80 Assists,
könnt ihr euch auch gestern dran erinnern, richtig krasse Runde und am Ende, wisst ihr
was am Ende angezeigt wurde, 10 Hipfire Kills, ich hatte, jetzt sterbt er, ich hatte 70 Kills
und 80 Assists und es wird einfach mal angezeigt, 10 Hipfire Kills, ich mein, what the fuck,
was ist mit euch falsch, es gibt keinen Scoreboard, ja das hast du richtig verstanden, kein Scoreboard,
du hast, ich zeig dir was du als Scoreboard hast, du hast da nicht wirklich viel, du hast,
also wenn ich hier durch bin und vielleicht das irgendwie überlebe, zeige ich dir das,
Boris, gecommodet, gecommodet Boris am Start, ok alles down, einfach voll überrannt, easy,
das einzige was du hast ist, du hast einmal das hier, du siehst halt nichts außer dein
eigenes Squad, kein nix, dass sie nicht einer gekränkt fühlen könnte oder so und wenn du
den Tab drückst siehst du halt dein eigenes Squad, ok das war's, das ist alles, was halt
eigentlich ja viel zu wenig ist, wenn du mich fragst, ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen,
dass sie das jetzt ändern, weil der Aufschrei so groß war und wisst ihr was passiert, wisst
ihr was passiert wenn die das ändern, dann sagen die Leute wieder, ich hab's doch gleich
gesagt, gebt dem Spiel einfach ein bisschen Zeit, aber nein daran liegt es nicht, wenn
sowas gepatcht wird dann einzeln allein weil der Aufschrei zu groß war, weil das sind
Dinger sind, die sind einfach, man es ist immer der Gegner wo du nicht hinguckst, immer
der Gegner der dich von der Seite weg penetriert, dabei war das wieder eine richtig coole Aktion
oben drauf, wir hätten jetzt 5 Kills machen können, aber nein, gibt's nicht und wenn
die das patchen, oh und wie gesagt wenn die das patchen ist es nicht weil sie es eingesehen
haben, sondern weil sie gedacht haben, fuck die Leute flamen uns ja des Todes, äh entweder
Boomer Ice oder der war einfach schwarz mit der Wand verschmolzen gerade, dachte der ist
im nächsten Raum, wahrscheinlich Boomer Ice, was sagt ihr, hat man den gesehen oder waren
das Safe Boomer Ice ok, ich dachte es mir schon fast, ich dachte es mir schon fast,
wobei ich das halt nicht so genau nachvollziehen kann, weil guckt euch mal Warzone an, warum
ist hier keine Tür, ist hier wirklich keine Tür, gibt's hier nur 2 Türen, guckt euch
mal Warzone an, Warzone war so der letzte große Hit, der dann auch letztendgültig Battle
Royale vercasualisiert hat für Tante Brunhilde, aber trotzdem Warzone hat immer noch richtig
krasse Skill Moves die du machen kannst, das darf man nicht vergessen, das ist zwar mit
SPMM und allem easy Einsteiger freundlich, aber du kannst immer noch richtig heftige
Moves machen, von wo überhaupt, ach da von Boris, easy easy clap Boris und ich sag euch
Leute das Game hat auch Skill Best Matchmaking hier, das will nur keiner wahrhaben, das ist,
ich merke das, ich spiel hier doch nicht gegen absolute Kacknoobs die vor einem Tag angefangen
haben oder vor 2 Tagen, kann mir keiner erzählen, die können vor allem weil die alle schon
gerade aus aimen können ist das nicht der Fall, so die richtig ultra Kacknoobs die können
doch nicht weil keine 3 Meter gerade aus aimen, wenn das ein richtiger Kacknoob gewesen wäre,
den hätte ich, den hätte ich gehipf heiert, den hätte ich gehipf heiert und er hätte
mich nicht getroffen, das hat wieder wunderbar funktioniert, so wir können jetzt unsere
Massive Hook, Crappling Hook Moves machen sobald er aufgeladen ist, in der Hoffnung er
geht nicht kaputt, weiß, doch er geht nicht, sehr schön, da ist ein Panzer, Fenceman, 30
Millimeter geschützt jawoll, meinst du das man das Spiel noch retten kann, tja, ich glaub
das ist die größte Frage die sich alle gerade stellen, also meine Meinung dazu ist, also
das Spiel hat keinen sonderlich guten Kern, so wie es jetzt ist, das einfachste was man,
what the fuck, das ist einfach verschwunden, ok, das einzige was man jetzt machen kann
ist, also was ich machen würde, ich würde die Maps, neue Grenzen ziehen und aus einer
großen Map einfach 1-3 kleine Maps machen, oh der ist nicht gestorben Alter, der hat
3 Headshots oder so gehabt, nichts, jetzt können wir aber MP9 spielen, also die könnten
aus einer Map 1-3 kleinere Maps machen, weil guck mal, dieses Areal hier und drum herum
könnte man vielleicht sogar eine 32-64 Spieler, hier so dieses Areal, ne halbwegs gute 32
Mann, 64 Mann, 48 Mann Map draus machen, hier oben auch, raus und schon hätte man 2,
Spiel eine Runde mit einem anderen Account, ja klar, ich kauf mir das Spiel aber nochmal
auf dem anderen Account, oh das macht so viel Damage auf die Entfernung, ok, Massive Big
Brain Move, Alter, warum ist es so broken, ich meine der Crap-Leak ist das geilste Attachment,
aber wenn das sollte halt mal funktionieren, so wir gehen jetzt da drauf, ok ich weiß nicht
wo was ist, vielleicht hier, ok nice, Armored Kill, hey ich glaube 128 Spieler auf Armored
Kill würde besser funktionieren als hier, möchte es öffnen please, machen wir wieder
zu, wie kann man hier innen drinnen nicht weiter, aber das ist wahrscheinlich nicht
offen genug, da haben sie sich gedacht, nope, seriously, alter ich hasse dieses Game, das
ist der Wahnsinn, das ist, die Dinger von der MP-19 sind da straight durch den Kopf
geflogen, das letzte war PP-Gard, aber das davor ist echt der Wahnsinn, ja ich finde
auch 128 Spieler, weil das ist nicht die krasseste Idee, Alter, könnt ihr mal sterben, ich weiß
nicht wo ich hin soll, einfach so auf links rechts laufen, hier geht hier was, oben drauf,
Bashen, Alter, Bashen, oder muss ich doch wieder PP-Gard 29 raushauen, 128 Spieler,
also mehr Flaggen, Patrick, ich muss sagen, auf die Idee bin ich noch gar nicht gekommen,
128 Spieler mit mehr Flaggen, ich glaube das wäre gar keine so schlechte Idee, wobei
ich sagen muss, ich finde den Ansatz, hier drei kleine, guck mal, da kannst du eine
kleine 64 Spieler Map draus machen, 32, 64 Spieler und da, den Rest der Map kannst du
einfach, die Map, die brauchst du, guck mal, dieses Areal hier, das wäre eine ganz, vielleicht
das hier noch dabei, was auch immer das ist, das wäre tatsächlich eine ganz gute 64 Spieler
Map, mal anderen Sitz, ich sprähe da jetzt einfach mal rein, ok, da musst du Shroud sein,
das ist hinter dir, glaube ich, ok, wechseln wir wieder, Alter, was machst du hier, Schneiber
Dude, von hinten kommt irgendwas, oh, der Pantsman ist hinter uns, der Pantsman ist
hinter uns, das war aber close, das war richtig close, der hat uns gerade richtig, oh ne, da
ist der nächste Pantsman am Start, ich hoffe einfach, wir überleben das, ok, nice, nichts
geht, macht der Boomer-Arm nicht mehr mit, ok, wir gehen raus und vielleicht haben wir
Glück und können hier hoch, nein, nein, ohne zu sterben, lull, was ist der Mehrwert von
so vielen Spielern, ja, das musste Dice fragen, das verstehe ich auch nicht, das verstehe
ich auch nicht so genau, also, ja doch, doch ich verstehe es, ich weiß, was der Mehrwert
ist, der Mehrwert ist, dass man Marketing technisch, gut damit, warum werde ich denn hier unten
gesportet, man, dass man Marketing technisch, gut damit werben kann, bin Stuck, bin Stuck,
was zum, ok, game, sag mal, was ist mit diesem Spiel, was ist mit diesem Spiel, ich verstehe
es nicht, das ist gerade, ja, das sieht aus, als ist die Leiter-Hitbox einfach ans Meter
nebendran, Wahnsinn, gut, dass du uns was gesagt hast, Sonnens, ja, die 34 normalen
Kills, die interessieren keinen, 11 als Passenger, die sind wichtig, Outstanding Performance,
welches Squad habt ihr geguckt, welches Squad, welcher Platz, welchen Platz im Squad-Ranking
waren wir, hat irgendjemand aufgepasst, hier, ja, das ist ok, wie gesagt, mit Top 5 bin
ich zufrieden, Top 5 ist in dem Spiel, weil, als Infanterie-Squad, du spielst ja gegen
die ganzen Heli-Owner und Hovercraft-Owner und so, und ich spiele so gut wie nie Hovercraft
und wir fliegen so gut wie nie Heli, das einzige, was wir die Runden gemacht haben, ist am Anfang
ein bisschen Jeep gefahren, Biotech, dazu kann ich bloß sagen, wo ist die Frage, hier,
also sprich, hey Leute, soll man sich als alter Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4 Fan das
Game zulegen oder lieber noch warten mit MegaHenrys, also ich kann dir da meine Meinung zu sagen
und die lautet, nein, du solltest dir das besser nicht zulegen, wenn du Battlefield
3 und Battlefield 4 Fan bist, zumindest im aktuellen Zustand nicht, und ob der Zustand
sich jemals großartig bessert, ach, oh, Discarded, sehr gut, Discarded, das haben wir schon lange
damit gespielt und Discarded, die erste Flex in Discarded sind auch so gut platziert, also
ich kann mir so richtig das Design Meeting, das Daily Scrum, ich kann mir richtig gut
das Daily Scrum vorstellen von Dice, wo sie die Discarded Breakthrough besprochen haben,
da kam so der erste Dice Typ, hat gesagt, guck mal, wir haben hier ne riesige Map ohne was
drauf, wie machen wir da Breakthrough, dann legst du halt, weißt du was, mach einfach
da zwei Container mehr hin und stell die Flagge hin, die Spieler merken schon nicht, dass
das ne doofe Idee ist, dann hat der Chef gesagt, Jungs, Gehaltserhöhung, Poggers Idee und
jetzt die Map im Spiel, jetzt müssen wir mitleben, das war halt einfach agiles Daily
Scrum, was uns das gebracht hat, das Scrum Master war an dem Tag einfach nicht da und
warum muss man sich halt die Sprüche jedes Mal neu anhören, gut, wir können keinen
MP9 spielen auf die Range, das geht nicht, es ist ja aber auch komisch, ne, in nem Spiel,
das mehr Battlefield Ranges hat, also mehr Range hat als jedes andere Battlefield, hat
man sich so überlegt, wir machen nur, wir machen alle Waffen auf Range, Scheiße, hat
irgendjemand diesen 5 Head, 6 Head, 11 Head Gedankengang verstehen, ich mein, ok, vielleicht
versteh ich auch diese Obvious Genialität nicht, das wird's wahrscheinlich sein, aber
es sind ja alle Waffen, bis auf die DMR, Scheiße auf Range, also Pepega 29 und DMR,
der Rest ist Trash auf Range, Sniper lass jetzt mal außen vor, weil das ja offensichtlich,
dass die, zumindest die One Shot Sniper auf Range ganz ok ist, aber so von den normalen
Waffen, das ist ja eigentlich alles Trash auf Range, bis auf zwei Waffen oder bis auf
eine Waffe und eine Waffenkategorie, oh guck mal, ein Hovercraft, wer hätte das gedacht,
dass ein Hovercraft kommt, das kommt ja so selten vor, ah, ein Armorplate, sehr gut,
er hat mich aus PBX'd, aber nicht gut getroffen, so was ist denn hier los, warum, ja, warum
sind hier schon wieder so viele Gegnerfahrzeuge, da brauchen wir jetzt Anti-Fahrzeug-Granaten,
das ist auch so ne Big Brain Design Idee, ne, Leute, Anti-Fahrzeug-Granaten, ich mein,
the fuck, Anti-Fahrzeug-Raketen, ok, aber Zielsuchende Anti-Fahrzeug-Granaten, weiß
nicht, aber eins kann ich sagen, nachdem ich heute Hazard Zone gespielt hab, muss ich sagen,
ich verstehe das Specialist-Konzept nun deutlich besser, das Specialist-Konzept klappt in Hazard
Zone, klappt tatsächlich deutlich besser, seht ihr, wie die abgeht, die Granate, die
flutscht mal richtig, Pipega 29, man, ist Hazard Zone Battle Royale, ne, Hazard Zone
ist, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das, ich versuch mal Hazard Zone zu erklären, also,
du hast random auf der Map irgendwelche Festplatten, die gespawnt sind, nein, und es spawnen 8 Teams
rein, die die Festplatten sammeln sollen, dafür hat man so nen Scanner, da guckt man
durch und sieht, wo die sind, und dann geht man dahin und sammelt die und alle, fragt
mir nicht, 10 Minuten oder so, oder 5 Minuten, ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht, ha, ha,
gutes Spiel, gutes Spiel, gutes Spiel, und alle paar Minuten kommt so ein Hubschrauber
und wenn du diesen Hubschrauber reingehst, fliegt er dich raus und du bekommst Rewards,
vielleicht sind Battlefield-Patches drauf, krieg ich nen Rätts, Leute, krieg ich nen
Rätts, krieg ich nen Rätts, ihr Ehrenmänner, ach ne, ich kann nicht gerätzt werden, weil
ich stecke ja in der Wand, hab ich ganz vergessen, das geht ja nicht, wenn man auch nur nen Pixel
in der Wand steckt, kann man nicht wiederbelebt werden, man muss es ja nicht übertreiben,
in Bad Company 2, das war so nicht geplant by the way, in Bad Company 2 konnte man durch
die Wand wiederbeleben, das war vielleicht auch nicht so gut, aber ich finde, es hat
seinen Scham, dass man wiederbelebt werden kann, was hier in dem Spiel hoffentlich nicht
funktioniert und das wiederbeleben ich schon ziemlich schwierig jetzt.
Ist der Typ jetzt down?
Ich glaub, der ist down.
Okay, nice, ich mag die Base hier lieber, weil hier ist der Kran und mit dem Kran...
Ey, clusterfuck, übrigens, ich muss euch jetzt dazu mal nen Quote zeigen aus meinem
Video und dann müsst ihr mir sagen, Max, du bist einfach nur Boomer-Kacknut mittlerweile
oder ihr müsst sagen, das ist ne doofe Idee gewesen, was der Typ geschrieben hat und zwar...
Oh fuck, da kamen ja mittlerweile schon wieder so viele...
Okay, ich find's jetzt, hier, hier, da war's.
Chrome?
Genau, also, ich sag bei 10, 15, für einen Gegner, den du siehst, sehen dich 5 und der
sagt, da braucht man einfach die Reactions für.
Also, ich hätte, dass ich das überlebe, ich hätte einfach die Reactions gebraucht.
Hätte ich die Reactions gehabt, hätt ich die jetzt alle wegbashing können, aber ich
hatte die Reactions einfach nicht.
Wie steht ihr dazu?
Die, die Reactions fehlen einfach.
Vielleicht, vielleicht sollte ich, vielleicht sollte ich ein bisschen mehr, nein, nicht
rausfahren, Hovercraft, wir müssen hier spawnen, nice, sehr gut, weiter geht's, wir müssen
dahin.
Ey, es ist wieder durchgeflogen, meine Güte, man.
Wie soll man auf 40 FPS werden, das kommt ja auch noch dabei.
Bei den FPS krasse Reactions haben wir, die sind oben, oder, oder hier oben, oder da,
ne, Dach, die sind auf dem Dach, Dachstelz, so war das nicht geplant, ich wollte eigentlich
hier rausspringen, aber, der ballert mich weg, war so klar, vielleicht kriege ich ein Rätsel
hinter dir, das wäre schon sehr nice.
Oh, guckt euch das mal an, Teammates des Jahres, sind die jetzt unter uns, oder, oder
wo, oder was, man, aber hier Teammates des Jahres, Pog, oh, was ist da oben, holen wir
ihn hier, zack, Captain Pogger ist am Start, jetzt geht's, jetzt geht's rein.
Einfach nicht die Reactions, den da hinten hätte ich jetzt theoretisch auch instant
Headshotten müssen, sind einfach nicht die Reactions da, obviously, muss halt reacten,
das war übrigens nicht der, den wir gesehen haben, das war noch ein ganz anderer Typ,
ey, das Spiel macht mich fertig, ziel halt auf den Kopf, just, just, just do it, just
Headshot, just down lose, okay, ne, da machst du nichts mehr, ihr seht, das Skarnet ist
richtig gut am Anfang, wir werden jetzt gebashed, nein, nein, nein, nein, just click der Herz,
so sieht's aus, easy, krasser Teamplayer, guck mal an, der hat Armourplates verteilt,
richtig krasser Teamplayer, massiver Teamplayer würde ich sogar sagen, so, ich muss da mal
hoch und ein Stückchen fliegen, weil ansonsten bringt mir der Wingsuit ja gar nichts, falls
ich, falls ich da überhaupt, nein, das geht natürlich nicht, PP29, ihr seht ja, eigentlich
ist die PP29 genau das, wie die Waffen für das Spiel sein müssen, du brauchst mehr Munition,
weil du hast halt einfach immer mal 40 Gegner, die du potenziell schießen musst und du
brauchst Waffen, die auf Range halbwegs brauchbar sind, also das Waffendesign verstehe ich überhaupt
nicht, du hast, du hast nichts, außer die PP29 und DMRs, die dir so irgendwie so, weil
die Assault Rifles halt einfach mal Hardcore satten, nichts, was du eigentlich auf diese
Ranges gescheit spielen kannst, da bin ich, frage mich auch so, okay, wer ist auf die
klorreiche Idee gekommen, dass das, dass das so eine gute Idee ist, oh, Moritz, ich hole
dich, oh, der ist wieder rauf hier, nein, oh, Covid-Impfung reingejagt, ich hole dich
wieder, Team Ed des Monats Award, nein, pass auf, ich genieße die große Deckung, die hier
ist, oh, diese Deckung, ich habe mich gleich viel sicherer gefühlt hinter der Deckung,
da sind die Booster Shots, genau, vielleicht mal Motion Sensoren mal hier rumfeuern, Motion
Sensor feuern, so, wo sind denn Gegner hier, zeig mal, sieht man hier irgendwas, seht ihr,
wo ich bin auf der Map, chat, wo bin ich auf der Map, seht ihr es, wo bin ich, ich bin
da, wem das nicht aufgefallen ist, da, ich bin, ah, ah, ach, da hinten ist er, man, also
falls ihr es nicht erkannt habt, ich wäre da gewesen, hier, obviously, die Heal Operatorin,
du bist so zu schwach, nee, finde ich gar nicht, du meinst hier, die deutsche Oma, nee, finde
ich gar nicht, das ist eigentlich eines der besten, ich zeige dir gleich mal, warum die
richtig gut ist, ich switch gleich mal, erinnert mich dran, falls ich es vergesse, ihr wisst,
mein Hirn ist nicht mal so voll bei der Sache hier, wenn ich spielen muss, nebenbei, die
ist richtig gut, ich zeig dir gleich, warum, ich versuche mal dich, hallo, warum, das Game,
man, das Game, sie kann doch mit der Pistole auf Range heilen, so, also warum ich die Oma
richtig gut finde, ist, dass man, nehmen wir da jetzt mit, vielleicht komme ich hier noch
rein, vielleicht habe ich Glück, kann ich beim Zeroes Max oder beim Ding spawnen, ach,
nee, auf Range Redzen können, ok, so, weil du kannst mit der Pistole, du kannst auf
die Erde schießen und rüberlaufen und dich heilen, ich mache das aber nicht, weil das
manchmal verbackt ist, aber das ist eigentlich richtig OP, ich persönlich spiele aber lieber
mit Mobility Specialist als mit der Oma, aber trotzdem würde ich sagen, wenn ich den Tier-Ranking
machen müsste, von den Specialists, würde ich sagen, Maria Falck ist S Tier, Maria Falck
und Sundance sind S Tier, Webster ist Art A Tier, weil er eigentlich der beste Specialist
ist, wie ich finde, nur, dass die Maps zu wenig Möglichkeiten geben für seinen Grappling-Hook,
ich, Alter, ich habe noch nicht mal Planen, wo er irgendwas schießt, da kriege ich nichts,
oh nee, der hat mich tatsächlich, der hat mich geholt, wahrscheinlich, jawoll, gib ihm,
gib ihm, gib ihm, jawoll, huge, huge, massive spawn, ok, das war keine gute Idee, hier oben
drauf zu gehen, das gibt es nämlich auf dem Sack gleich, jawoll, guck, jetzt kannst du
einfach drüber laufen, hast du es gesehen, das ist richtig POG, richtig POG, wir verlieren
Leute, wir verlieren Leute, habt ihr es gehört, wenn die das sagt, dann weiß man, es ist ernst,
dann ist es ernst, ok, wir müssen hier weg, das geht nicht, kann ich, ich sollte mal meinen
Raketenwerfer nachladen, ich meine, du kannst halt legit nirgends wohin, ja klar, na klar,
schon drauf geschossen, bevor ich um die Ecke gekommen bin, oder anders, wie lange bleibt
der Heel auf dem Boden, das ist eine gute Frage, das weiß ich nicht, das weiß ich
nicht, oh nee, hier kann mich keiner retten, nee, nee, lass, lass, lass Leute, das kann
mich, das weiß ich nicht, da bin ich überfragt, wie lange das auf dem Boden bleibt, wahrscheinlich
nicht allzu lang, Squad, wir sacken die Runde, aber ich auch, ich weiß aber auch nicht, was
ich hier großartig anders machen soll gerade, oh Hovercraft, nice, ich renne jetzt hier
einfach mal hinter, vielleicht bringt das was, hier, big treestells, game, F, ich drücke
F für Melee, hallo, F, F, ich will den Zaunmessern, F, alter, so abfucktes Spiel, man, der macht
keinen Nahkampfangriff, den Zaunmessern, ja, dann geht der kaputt, das ist kein Nahkampfangriff,
der geht einfach nicht, es ist einfach nicht möglich, Nachkampfangriff zu machen, wir
haben gewonnen, Painschamp, so ein Painschamp, ich muss euch ja sagen, ich fand die Animation
in der Beta, wo die mit der Faust auf den Zaun, wo die mit der Faust auf diesen Zaun
gehauen haben und der Zaun ist dann explodiert, fand ich viel besser, das hatte ich auch schon,
das linke und rechte Maustaste nicht funktioniert haben, das merkst du halt, wenn du nicht schießen
kannst oder nicht ADS gehen kannst, das ist so kaputt alles, was macht die Omi da, die
heilt, Leute, eigentlich heilt die sich zum größten Teil selbst, wie findest du die XP
Vergabe, habe ich jetzt, habe ich ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so viel Augenmerk drauf
gelegt, weil ich meistens mit Motion Sensor unterwegs bin, dementsprechend relativ viele
Assists habe, aber eigentlich ist es okay, weil man levelt eh saumäßig schnell, ich
bin jetzt was, 45, chat fragt, wieso ist der Sani eine Oma und keine Frau mit blonden Haaren,
wahrscheinlich wäre das zu schwedisch, keine Ahnung, das muss ja möglichst divers und
international sein, der Cast of Characters, da kannst du nicht einfach schwedisches blondes
Grill rein machen oder Mercy in Overwatch, schweizer blondes Schweizer Grill, das geht
nicht, was kommt jetzt für eine Map, hoffentlich mal eine gescheite Map, Manifest zum Beispiel
wäre sehr nice, wenn jetzt Manifest kommt oder, oder vielleicht, ah, Manifest, wie
wollte ich sagen, vielleicht Renewal, Manifest, Pog, vielleicht sogar Attacker, Postchamp,
vielleicht dürfen wir Attacker spielen, das wäre sehr nice, Manifest Attacker, das ist
eigentlich die einzige Map, die ich wirklich gerne spiele, Manifest Attacker, Prege, Leute,
Prege, Prege, Prege Chat, Prege, Prege, Manifest Attacker, die Sprüche sind so dumm, ok, ok,
Prege, Prege, ja, Alter, laber nicht, ich will sehen, ob ich Attacker oder Defender, ich
bin Attacker, Bam, jawoll, Pog, Attacker Manifest, sehr gut, das mag ich, was heißt das jetzt,
Prege ist dieses Emote aus dem Chat, der, der, der macht halt Prege, Setge macht er, Prege
macht er, was gibt es noch für Ge-Emotes, außer Pp-Ga, Setge, Prege, Betge, Betge, Vogue,
Vogue, Betge, ja, das habe ich aber nicht, oh, guck mal, oh, Vollhaus hier, wir fliegen
jetzt in die Luft, Leute, ich sage euch, wir haben noch 10 Sekunden zu leben, dann sind
wir down, weil irgendwas merkwürdiges passiert, oder wir gegen die Wand fahren, übrigens
jetzt immer ernsthaft, das ist das beste Geschoss für das Auto, was wir hier haben, 30mm, 30mm
Geschoss, Alter, die machen mich fertig hier, die krassen Drivers, die krassen Drivers
hier, aber richtig, Leute, aber richtig, Monkastier, glaubst du auch, dass Battlefield 20 sein
Spiel des Jahres werden könnte, natürlich, also bei diesem grandiosen Launch, und dadurch,
dass das Jahr ja quasi fast zu Ende ist, also mit diesem Launch, da ist ja quasi Game of
the Year fast schon gesichert, vielleicht kriegt es auch den deutschen Computerspiele-Preis,
der ist ja international sehr begehrt, habe ich gehört, den wollen sie alle haben, der
ist so begehrt, dass die Preisempfänger noch nicht mal erscheinen, um den Preis entgegen
zu nehmen. Wird das das letzte Battlefield sein? Nö, wahrscheinlich nicht. Huck, Huckge,
man, warum fickt mich immer einer von der Seite? Egal, wo du hinguckst, das Spiel kriegt
den, was für ein Ding, den silbernen Bravo-Otto, gab es das früher mal, da war ich wahrscheinlich
noch nicht, wo ich mich dafür interessiert habe. Oh, guck mal da, da nehmen wir jetzt
MP9, ich muss was anderes als diese Kackwaffe hier immer spielen. Guck mal, und jetzt kommt
sogar Schalldämpfer drauf, Stels-Modus aktiviert, Stels-Modus aktiviert. Krasser Hacker, Dude,
richtig krasser Hacker, man. Alter, ich krieg... Ich wollte da übrigens, by the way, nicht
hochklettern, sage ich euch, ne? Okay, alles klar. Ist Sliden eigentlich schneller als
normales Laufen? Hm, das ist eine gute Frage, also ich weiß nicht, ob du mit Laufen, Sliden,
Laufen, Sliden irgendwie schneller bist, aber du hast einen Vorteil, die Gegner hinten dich
nicht so einfach. Deswegen finde ich schon, dass es nicht verkehrt zu Sliden, weil man
Sliden kann. Welches Battlefield spielt ihr im Moment? Das ist 2042, das ist das latest
and greatest Battlefield experience, wenn du nach DICE gehst. Da, da, Bashing, Alter,
Alter. Oh, wir wurden gehackert, man. Richtig, richtige Hacksaw am Start. Okay, hier sieht
man wieder, du kannst nur PP-Gar 29 spielen, ich hab keine Range, um irgendwie auch nur
ansatzweise irgendwas zu killen. Ich hab hier nice Flanks, Stells am Start, aber kann nichts
machen, ich hab keine Range, man. Dankeschön, dass ich das Ding ins Gesicht bekommen hab.
Ich bekomme immer gerne Raketenwerfer ins Gesicht, ich find das richtig geil. Geht mir immer
einer ab. Habt, seht ihr, wie genau man da sich anstrengen muss zu aim, um mit dem Ding
was zu killen? Mega anstrengend, einfach PP-Gar 29 draufspammen, um gut ist. Ja, nice.
Ach, da, obvious, obvious, obviously ist da jemand. Da hätte man ja mal mit rechnen können.
Okay, weiter geht's. Durch hier. Achtung, Massive Brain Move. Fuck.
Da kommt gleich was. Nice. Oh, ich hab keine Heal Packs mehr, fuck. Aber vielleicht, Leute,
könnt ihr bei mir ein Spine spawnen, ich bleib safe, nice. Dieses fucking Game, Alter.
Okay. Hast du das Halo schon getestet? Nein, ich hab das seit 5 Tagen, also seit, wie ich
es runtergeladen hab und nicht probiert. Aber ich will es unbedingt mal endlich ausprobieren,
weil ich glaube, ich dreh langsam durch, ich verlier wirklich die letzten Gehirnzellen,
wenn ich das hier spiele. Warum kriegen wir eigentlich so extremst auf den Sack? Macht
mehr Spaß als Ben. Wie ist denn das, Leute? In Halo 3 war es halt so, dass du als Halo-Noob
erst mal 2 Monate üben musstest, bis du irgendwie halbwegs was auf die Reihe gekriegt
hast. Wie ist das in dem Halo? Also, kann man das auch als Halo-Noob, kann man da reinkommen,
ohne dass man erst mal richtig krass einen Crime machen muss? Weil mein letztes Halo
ist halt schon ein bisschen her. Am PC kommt man generell reicht rein? Ja, ich glaube, das
war ja auch eines der Ziele, die sie hatten, dass man dieses Halo auch jetzt als Einsteiger
da erst mal ganz gut spielen kann. Ey, das Spiel ist einfach Müll. TwitchTV, okay, den
Typ müssen wir killen. Der Typ müssen wir killen, TwitchTV im Namen. Warum muss man
bei Halo 3 so stark crime? Weil Halo so einen ganz speziellen Flow hatte und die Gegner
halt auch viel ausgehalten haben und dementsprechend musstest du erstens dich schon wirklich gut
an Xbox Controller gewöhnen. Alter, kann das? Einfach mal, was ist denn hier los?
Ach, das ist ein fucking Ranger, das ist gar kein Gegner. Es kann mir doch keiner erzählen,
dass ich hier gegen absolute Noobs spiele. Das kann mir keiner erzählen, das ist SBMM,
Leute. Nee, wobei ganz ehrlich, ich glaube nicht, dass es SBMMt ist. Ich glaube, es
ist einfach das beschissenste Map-Design, was es jemals in Battlefield gegeben hat.
Ich meine, die Maps passen so gar nicht zu der Spieleranzahl. Der Typ kann einfach da
uncontested oben stehen, ohne dass ihm irgendwas passiert. Ich mein, da fuck man. Geh mir nicht
auf den Sack. Jetzt bin ich mad, Alter. Mein Gott, ey, was hat man sich dabei gedacht?
Ich krieg wirklich Anfälle gerade. Doch ich hab erst mal einen gebannt, erst mal Rage
gebannt. Das kann es doch wirklich nicht sein. Entspannt reden bringt nichts mehr, Leute.
Was ist das hier? Oh nee, nee, nee. Wenn ich jetzt Bad Company 2 spiele, geht ja gar
nicht. Oh fuck. Zedge. Das Maul. Endspann Nahkampf-Kill. Gib ihm. Ja, ich hab ihn, ich hab
ihn. In your face. Der Typ ist down. Wie lange dauert ein Melee-Kill? Sehr lange. Das
war ein Abschied. Also wenn du lang drückst, dann macht er so einen komischen Melee-Kill
ansonsten nicht. Sorry an den, den ich irgendwie gebannt hab eben, äh, gemuted hab. Ich hab
mich ein bisschen aufgeregt über das Game. Was glaube ich echt verständlich ist, wenn
man sich das anguckt. Ah. Komm mal dahinten. Da wird schon geschneibt. Wie verrückt. Vielleicht
können wir mal irgendwas spawnen. Wenigstens so hier, komm. Take Downs sind drin für
Cosmetic Items, korrekt. Hauptsächlich für Cosmetic Items sind hier drinnen. Das ist
richtig. Da wollte er mich einfach mit dem M5 in die Luft sprengen. Einfach so. Hat
ich gedacht. Ja. Freige. Oh guck mal, ich hab Heidi Klum gekillt. Ach nee, Heidi Klum.
Ah, nicht Heidi Klum. Heidi. Heidi. Okay, ich, ich kann hier nicht raus. Wenn ich hier,
wenn ich meinen Kopf hier raus stecke, dann bin ich deadge. Aber richtig massiv deadge.
Ah, intelligenter Roboter. Ich muss hier oben rumstellen, sonst geht nicht. Ah, der ist
down. Nix wie weg. Ah, nein. Ah Mist, ich dachte man kommt da rüber. Nochmal kurz rauf
und hopp. Oh da unten, guck mal da. Habt ihr es gesehen? Irgendwas, irgendwas schießt
hier auf mich. Ich hab gar keine Ahnung was. Der hat sich jetzt auch gedacht, wo the fuck
kommt der Typ her? Haben wir uns gegenseitig gekillt? Ja, wir haben uns gegenseitig gekillt.
Bitte ist es auch so schwierig in diesem Battlefield mehr als 3 Kills in Folge zu machen. Es ist
nahezu unmöglich mehr als 3 Kills in Folge zu machen. Wir haben es Leute. Wir haben es.
Der Jäger hat geholfen. Einzig und allein weil der Chat gepraet hat. Die haben übrigens
auch die Strecke die du zurücklegen kannst mit dem Fallschirm seit der Beta glaube ich
genervt. In der Beta konntest du total weit fliegen mit dem Fallschirm. Zumindest kommt
es mir so vor ob es wirklich so ist. Entschuldige. Hier liegen ganz viele. Ah nice. Ok ich dachte
es geht vielleicht durch. Du kannst ja mal probieren. Hey Max was für ein Setting spielst
du? Wenn ja läuft es flüssig. Ja siehst du da oben ja. 80 FPS. Ich würde es jetzt
nicht als ultra flüssig bezeichnen. Gerade zwischenzeitliche Slowdowns sind ganz eklig.
Exquisiter Spawn. Sehr gut da. Sehr gut reingespawnt unter der Erde. Ach ja hier ist ja viel Deckung.
Hier ist ja viel Deckung. Sehr gute Sache. Wenn ich tauchen könnte dann könnte man auch
und wie in Battlefield 4 tauchen. Aber das haben die Leute in 2042 verlernt. Ah ja guck
mal da. Was? Wo bin ich überhaupt? Ach ja das geht übrigens auch. Wer es zum ersten
mal sieht wird sich jetzt ein Abkerk wehen aber das ist normal in dem Spiel. Das Hovercraft
kann alles. Das ist gepanzert wie ein Tank. Das ist mobil. Das hat Firepower wie sonst
was. Hovercraft ist einfach das beste. So vielleicht kommen wir hier irgendwie rauf.
Ach guck mal auf der anderen Seite sind die. Für sowas ist der Crabling Hook wirklich
nice. Da macht es richtig Spaß. Deswegen finde ich ist das der beste Specialist. Leider
bieten die Maps zu wenig. Deswegen sage ich nicht dass es Astier ist. Astier ist Maria
Falk und Sandans finde ich. Ok wo genau sind die jetzt? Haben die Leute die Konsole spielen
auch so Probleme? Ja im Prinzip ja. Ich fasse es nicht. Da steht so ein Kackturm. Wo ist
der andere Typ hin? Ich höre was über mir. Oder auch nicht. Ich habe keine Ahnung wo
er angeblich gewesen sein soll. Ok hier erstmal da rein. So wo gehen wir denn jetzt hin? B1
wo ist denn das andere? B2 haben wir schon. Bleibt ja nur B1. Oh da kommt ein Auto. Sehr
viel. Ok ich glaube wir müssen B1. Was anderes bleibt uns gar nicht übrig. Wir verlieren
das. Natürlich blöd. Jetzt wäre Sandans nice. Jetzt wäre Sandans ziemlich pock. Mit dem
Wingsuit hier durch. Da steht einfach mal jemand. Obvius dass der da stand. Na klar
da muss man schon mal checken dass der da steht. Ja das kommt auch noch dabei das es
teilweise durchfliegt. Wir hatten doch schon alles erobert eben. Hä wie geht denn das
jetzt? Komm wir machen nochmal mp9. Wie geht denn das jetzt? Oh Mattress Pogger spawn. Alter
ich weiß nicht was hier abgeht aber. Alter Hacker Man. Hat er mich gesehen? Lad nach
mir bitte. Ok nein er hat keinen Bock. Ok das war von mir pp grad. Das war pp grad.
Jetzt hätte ich einen Schamm wissen. Ich weiß wo er war. Da oben ist er. Man es fickt
dich immer einer den du nicht siehst. Es ist einfach schrecklich. Oh Ehrenmänner hier
richtige Ehrenmänner. Richtig Ehrenmanns. Aber wo jetzt was ist? Da fliegt was runter.
Ok was? Motion Sensor. Ja den können wir. Nein nein nein. Ich weiß nicht genau von
wo. Was zum. Game. Come on. Irgendwann ist mit Vertikalität doch auch mal gut. Äh
man. Das ist eigentlich jetzt versteh ich das ist der 11 hat ein move von Dice. Wisst
ihr warum es hovercraft gibt? Weil die zu faul waren Schiffe einzubauen. Und die haben
sich einfach gedacht wir machen einen hovercraft dann brauchen wir weniger Panzer und wir brauchen
keine Schiffe machen. Alter Big Brain Move überhaupt. Jetzt hab jetzt hab ich das endlich
von wo von wo hab ich überhaupt beschossen. Jetzt hab ich das endlich verstanden. Ich
hab keine Ahnung von wo ich beschossen werde. Ich check es nicht. Die hatten zu wenig Zeit
für Schiffe. Die haben ja nur drei. Ok das geht nicht. Du musst pp 29 spielen. Du kannst
nichts anderes spielen. Es geht einfach nicht. Es geht einfach nicht. Du kannst nichts anderes
spielen. Es geht einfach nicht. Es geht einfach nicht. Es geht einfach nicht. Es geht einfach
nicht. Es geht einfach nicht. Es geht einfach nicht. Es geht einfach nicht. Es geht einfach
Oben bestimmt, da stellt es mich gleich von oben ab.
Sagt es euch.
Hier sind ja offensichtlich welche. Vielleicht gehe ich oben auf den Kran.
Oh, wäre das nice, wenn ich den spotten könnte.
Sehr gut, gleich haben wir es Leute.
Pepega Squad hat gesiegt, gleich haben wir es.
Der Angriff B ist erfolgt.
Hä? Hä? Hä?
Okay, das war Pepega ohne Ende.
Aber ich will ihn mit der Pistole baschen.
Ah, ich wusste es, dass wir dich mit der Pistole kriegen.
Die Pistole ist das Beste, was ihr im Nahkampf machen könnt.
Okay, oder mich vom Panzer wegschießen lassen.
Die Pistole ist so krass im Nahkampf im Burst Modus.
Das ein, das, das klatscht alles weg.
Kriegt man als Alpha Tester auch was gezahlt von EA?
Ja, ich kriege was bezahlt, wegen Sponsored Videos.
Zum Glück.
Was? Hä?
Was habe ich da gerade gesehen?
Okay.
Ich bin 21.
Und ich darf mich jetzt nicht beschweren.
Will das hier auch?
Ja, das war wirklich immer krasse Mario-Action.
Okay.
Das war krasse Mario-Action.
An Hovercraft.
Nice, lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Ey, ich kriege gerade wirklich Anfälle.
Okay, okay.
Das ist eine gute Idee von dem Gegner.
Wir sind Erster. Guck mal, Assassin Squad.
Assassiniert.
Machen wir jetzt auch.
Weil ich habe da eigentlich ein ganz gutes...
Oh, Poggers, Poggers, Poggers hier. Wo sind wir denn hier am Start?
Nice, C1, C1.
Ja, Poggers am Start.
Hier, wir brauchen den kurzen Lauf.
Das da und das.
Und werden Gachi-Bust vom Hovercraft.
Nee, Terminated. Von was genau wurde ich überhaupt getötet?
SBMM kickt rein.
Leute, ich habe echt die Vermutung.
Das sind keine Ultra-Noobs, die vor zwei Tagen angefangen haben hier.
Auf der anderen Seite sind 128 Spieler.
Die schießen einfach grob in die Richtung.
Und passt schon.
Guck mal.
Webster ist so geil, ne?
Aber das bringt jetzt gar nichts, dass ich jetzt hier gekrappelt habe.
Captain Poggers, ich hole dich.
Und ich... lasst mich in Ruhe, Leute.
Bam.
Sehr schön.
Jawoll, nice.
Hab ich dahinter uns was gesehen gerade?
Da ist er.
Vielleicht sehe ich von hier was.
Vielleicht kann ich den bashen hier. Hier ist gar nichts.
Wo ist er?
Ich dachte, hier ist einer.
Nope, nicht da.
Hier.
Dahinten, guck mal, da, da.
Da.
Guck mal, da, da.
Ach, der ist auf dem Kran.
Der schleibert uns jetzt gleich.
Habt ihr gesehen, der Midi-Stick hat nicht funktioniert.
Midi-Pen.
Okay.
Oh, oh.
Mann.
Die kommen hier gerade.
Die bashen mich.
Die Gachi basten mich weg.
Und mein scheiß Grappling-Hook funktioniert nicht.
Ich spiele jetzt was anderes.
Der war am Anfang, den haben die irgendwie kaputt gepatcht.
Der hat früher besser...
Der hat noch am Anfang der Woche besser funktioniert.
Ich mein, das kann doch nicht sein.
Dass es dann...
Dass das Gadget schlechthin ist.
Das einzige Gadget, was den Spielenswert macht.
Und dann funktioniert es nicht.
Jawoll.
All Seats Occupied.
Okay.
Vielleicht kriegen wir...
Da ist...
Ihr habt das beschissenste Battlefield aller Zeiten gebaut.
Das ist unglaublich.
Wie kann man so ein schlechtes Spiel machen?
Mal gucken, ich werde mir demnächst echt mal Halo angucken.
Also mein Langspiel...
Oh fuck, das war dumm.
Ich kann nicht mehr rennen.
Mein Sprint ist kaputt.
Komm, das kriegen wir jetzt.
C2 holen wir noch.
Massive.
So, nochmal hier.
Weil hier steht einer.
Hab ich zumindest gedacht.
Ich checke nicht wo, aber...
Motion Sensor.
Ach, da ist...
Da ist so ein komisches Sentry...
Sentry Ding.
Nice.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Checks, de wirklich wo hier was abgeht.
Aber wir scheinen vorwärts zu kommen.
Wir scheinen vorwärts zu kommen.
Das ist ja das wichtige.
Pin.
Corona Booster Impfung.
Alter, ich kriege gerade wirklich Anfälle, es funktioniert ja nichts.
Ich bin gestartet, drücke S, aber nein, wallbang, bamm, streckt, jetzt müssen wir hier, da
steht, da steht, ich weiß nicht von wo, ich hab keine Ahnung von wo, ich, ich, ach das
ist so ein fucking Ranger, Monkars, Monkars, richtiger Monkars Moment hier, bisschen Headglitchen,
bisschen Headglitchen geht immer, einfach mal richtig, richtig nice Headglitch machen,
ein nicer Headglitch, gut geheadglitched ist halb gewonnen, das kennt man doch aus
anderen Games, oder der Heli, oder der Heli bumst einen weg, macht der Ranger eigentlich
auch irgendwas, ja, der schießt über 300 Meter einen an und finisht einen, wenn man
Pech hat, ich ganz ehrlich Leute, obwohl ich mich aufrege, wir sind, nein, wir sind eigentlich
ganz gut, ich mein wir sind immer vorne, wir machen immer ganz gut Kills und das ohne
Ranger, Heli oder sonstigen Müll, wir spielen einfach ganz normal Infanterie das Game, ok
ich checke null was abgeht aber, ok wir gehen mal zurück, wir gehen mal weg, vielleicht
kommen wir hier nämlich durch, jetzt bräuchte ich doch wieder Webstar, jawoll, hat die gerade
gesagt fucker gott eliminated, hab ich das richtig verstanden, ich bin offended, ich
bin höchst offended, wie kann man dann solche language verwenden hier, also, horseman, ach
da war er, das hab ich jetzt nicht gesehen, Triggered, ja richtig Triggered, lass mich
auch mal Triggered sein, das ganze Game ist, das ganze Game triggert mich permanent, hab
ich euch eigentlich erzählt für alle die heute nicht dabei waren heute morgen, dass
Twitch meine, mein Watt gemutet hat, weil ich Hanzo, Hanzo Scatter nachgemacht hab und
die haben gedacht er sagt Scatter, das ist ja sowas wie Scheiße oder so, das muss man
natürlich muten, das ist, das geht nicht, ok Sundance sackt mal richtig hier, ich muss
jetzt Webstar auspacken, ich wollte gerade aus irgendwelchen Gründen sagen McCree, aber
das war ein anderes Game, häh, Monkers, Monkers, bester, bester Flyer, der musste sein, ich
weiß, dass McCree nicht McCree heißt mehr, ich muss was anderes spielen, mit Sundance
kommst du hier nicht rauf, vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht, nein, geht auch nicht, launchen
hier vorne, ok, Tango ist down, Tango Sucker, Tango Sucker, der übrigens gar nicht Tango
Sucker sagt, ja nice Sturmgewehr, beste, ja klar, Sturmgewehre sind so lächerlich,
ich dachte aber früher in MW2, wer dachte noch, dass die Typen in MW2 Tango Sucker sagen,
also Sucker, machen sie gar nicht, ok, ich nehme wieder den mit dem Crumbling Hook, der
sagt irgendwas Arabisches, Tango Sucker oder sowas, hört sich eh Sackert oder so, fragt
mich nicht, keine Ahnung, ich kann keine Ahnung, oh nein, ich hab Release, sorry, irgendwas
auf Arabisch sagen die in MW2, es hört sich halt an wie Tango Sucker, komm mal in Hovercraft,
das gab es ja schon lang nicht mehr, Aliens versus Hovercraft kommt demnächst, hab ich
gehört, oh, Game, man funktioniert doch einfach, Painschamp, ja ich geb's Hovercraft, war schon
sehr Painschampig der Witz gerade, ok, jetzt ist nix mehr da, da ist ein Sniper Dude übrigens,
guckt es euch mal an, so sieht es aus, wenn ein Game erlaubt, Selfheal und Ammo Boxen
auf dem gleichen Character zu haben, One Hit Sniper, Ammo Boxen und Selfheal auf dem
gleichen Character, das ist eine sehr sehr gute Idee, dass man sich an Rand der Map campen
kann und was weiß ich was der da macht während er spielt, keine Ahnung, ok, können wir es
jetzt einnehmen, wie ich mittlerweile, also ohne Scheiß, ich glaube, also heute spiel
ich das noch bis 23 Uhr oder so, wir gucken auch gleich mal die Reaction Videos noch,
ich glaube, ich hab ohne Scheiß, ich hab kein Battlefield so von den Mechanics und vom Gameplay
mehr gehasst als dieses Spiel, es ist einfach nur schlecht, du kannst es auch null kontrollieren,
haha, jebaited, du kannst es einfach null kontrollieren, du wirst immer von der Seite irgendwie reingeklärt,
wenn du kriegst so einen drauf, Hazard Zone besserer Modus, ja das stimmt, allerdings
finde ich Hazard Zone auch nicht irgendwie spielenswert, aktuell, und ich glaube, das
ist auch die, hat der gerade doppelt, hat der gerade doppelt Crabbling und gibt es da
einen Bug, den ich noch nicht kenne, ach guck mal, der Ventress weiß Bescheid, Grapple
in Place, ist schlecht, wenn das in Place wäre, schlechter als die Battlefield 3 Alpha,
ja aber deutlich, die Battlefield 3 Alpha war richtig, oh fuck, richtig nice, also ich
glaube, länger als die Woche, das ist der letzte Tag im Endeffekt, wo ich das Game
spiele, das ist jetzt durch, ich mein, ich bin, ich hab fast alles anlockt, ich hab alles
gesehen, soweit ich es sehen will, und ab jetzt ist es nur noch Payne, Paynes Champ,
und aufregen, und das muss nicht sein, dann spiel ich lieber ein bisschen Halo, oder ich
wollte ja auch schon unbedingt mit dem neuen Age of Empires spielen, also die Kampagne
Multiplayer bin ich zu schlecht, aber nicht im Stream oder so, sag ich gleich, ich wollte
mein Zoo weiter bauen, ich hab genug Sachen zum Spielen aktuell, dass ich mir den Kram
nicht mehr geben muss, Assassin hat, ach wir sind nicht mehr erster, weil der Captain
aus dem Squad raus ist, du machst Pause, ja okay, ich finde aber, guck mal, ich finde
die Punkte hätte man dem Squad ruhig lassen können, wenn das einer left, also wenn einer
aus dem Squad rausgeht, ich will da rein, lass mich rein, lass mich rein, lass mich rein,
alter lass mich rein, sind die alle so brain off, das ist ja keiner hier vom Stream, das
ist ja irgendwie der Random Dude, der da mit rein ist, okay, das hier erinnert jetzt ein
bisschen an Demavent Peak, und ihr werdet auch gleich die Referenz sehen, also hier gibt
es ja auch so, also kann man auch so einen Base Jump machen, dieser Base Jump ist aber
nur drinnen, um alte Fans abzuholen, dass sie das Spiel pre-ordern, um sie dann heftig
ausnehmen zu können, ach achja, langeschön Game, weiß nicht mal von wo, ah daneben, okay
gut, nein nein, da ist ein Hovercraft Mann, und ein Panzer, ey, das ist so voll, was geht
mit den Palmen ab, das ist ein bisschen wie aus die Witcher Palmen, die Witcher Bäume,
die haben sich ja auch so gebogen, ah hier ist Sturmgewehr, die Sturmgewehre, die sind
so schlecht Mann, lohnt das Game, nein, auf keinen Fall, lohnt nicht, aktuell lohnt das
nicht, nein, nein, also Leute, ich entschuldige mich jetzt schon mal bei euch, ich muss also
für alle, die das jetzt das letzte Mal so getriggert haben, ich muss morgen noch mal
ein Sponsor ein Video hochladen, aber erstens habe ich das vertraglich zugesichert, ist
das eine Shotgun, oder was ist das, Leute, habt ihr einen Plan, was das hier ist, ist
das eine Shotgun, das ist eine Durchschieße Shotgun, aber das muss sein, und dann habe
ich wenigstens ein bisschen was verdient an dem Game, oh, wir wollen Hacker-Ment, richtig
Hacker, Hacker, Hacker, oh von hinten, was kommt da von hinten, ah ja, obvios zu sehen,
ja, ja, ja, das läuft nirgendswo flüssig, ja, und ich habe auch CPU-Drops of Doom hier,
die Einschläge von diesem Ding lecken das Game übrigens, man kann nicht mehr weiterlaufen
wenn man gehitted wird von dem 30mm Geschütz, wie man gerade schön gesehen hat, könnte
kurz einer aus dem Tank aus, ah, nice, fuck, sag mal, was hält denn, der sah aus, als
das, ok, wie weit muss man hier eigentlich genau vorhalten, lol, ok, ich verpiss mich,
das soll so sein, alles in dem Game soll so sein, Bezehrheit, alles perfekt, ey ich kann
wieder nicht, ich kann nicht schießen, ich kann nicht schießen, mein ADS und meine linke
Maustaste gehen gerade einfach nicht, ich spiele einen Shooter, in dem ich nicht schießen
kann man, was zum Teufel ist das, was ist das für eine ausgeburte Hölle was ich hier
spiele, das ist doch nicht normal, das ist doch wirklich nicht normal, Problem, nein
alles gut, das kein Problem, get good reactions Leute, ihr habt es vorhin im Comment gesehen,
man braucht einfach die reactions dafür, ich habe einfach nicht die reactions gehabt,
allerweise ist doch hier ein, ah nee, hier ist es, ich kann da nicht runter, sorry, ok,
das ist einfach mal implodiert der Kopf von der, alter was ein clusterfuck, guckt euch
das mal an, man braucht einfach mehr reactions, also muss ja, also ich glaube viel besser
als so 54 22 Witz eigentlich in dem Game nennt und es macht halt trotzdem keinen Bock, deswegen,
ich sage es euch wie es ist, es ist wahrscheinlich heute der letzte Tag, Battlefield 2042, ich
habe alles gemacht, was ich machen will, Game fucked up, also spiele ich es nicht mehr,
alsbald das Game anfängt abzufucken und ich da mehr rumrage als Spastransform ist vorbei,
ja klar, ich hätte den gerade jetzt tracken sollen beim trüberspringen, der Chat, guck
mal, der Chat ist auch wahnsinnig, wahnsinnig happy, wir haben verloren, Pepehands, was
hältst du denn von Portal, gibt es da große Unterschiede zu den alten Teilen, ja, riesen
Unterschiede, oh cringe Gelaber, mach weg, also ne Runde können wir, oder 1-2 Runden
können wir noch spielen, wie gesagt bis 23 Uhr, was wollte ich denn sagen, ja ja, also
Battlefield 3 und Bad Company 2 in Portal haben nichts mit dem Original zu tun, das
einzige was da ist, es sind halt Maps aus dem jeweiligen, jeweils zwei Maps aus dem alten
Teil drinne, aber vom Gameplay, von den Mechanics, vom Momentum, von allem spielt sich das weder
wie Battlefield 3 noch wie Bad Company 2, die Reactions haben einfach gerade gefehlt,
ja, ist so, die Reactions haben gefehlt, zwei Major Patches, ich glaube ehrlich gesagt eher,
das Game, das braucht Preige, die müssen ihre erstgeborenen Opfern badise, dass das
noch was wird, anders kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass da noch was bei rumkommt, so, wir spielen
jetzt noch eine Runde, eine Runde spielen wir doch, es sei denn es sackt, dann range
quiddich, und dann gucken wir uns noch ein paar Battlefield Sachen auf YouTube an, wie
die Leute, also das Video vom Lost wollte ich mir auf jeden Fall angucken, der kotzt
sich ja auch ein bisschen drüber aus, gucken wir mal, und ich will wissen was er zu meinem
Video gesagt hat, es hat mich einer angeschrieben, hier guck mal, der sagt was zu deinem Video,
ich bin mal gespannt was er zu meinem Video sagt, aber weiß jemand wann er was zu meinem
Video sagt, also ich habe ab und zu bei ihm schon reingeguckt, ich glaube das ist ein
sehr, wie soll ich sagen, fähiger Battlefield, nee wie soll ich das ausdrücken, also ich
glaube dem, wenn der sagt, dass er das Spiel gut findet, dass es nicht rein aus Fanboy
ist, ich glaube der mag das Spiel wirklich, oh nee Breakthrough Orbital, das heißt, ich
lasse da jedem seine Meinung, deswegen interessiert mich einfach nur was er zu dem Video gesagt
hat, so in der Mitte, ja super, reagier doch mal auf das Video vom subreddit, du meinst,
dass, resit das Video, oder welches, der sagt auch, Leute ich sag's euch, das Pitpepega
29, wir haben es etabliert, das hat sich durchgesetzt, mach's gut Moritz, also das kann sein,
dass ich das Rage quitte, weil das hier wird nie eingenommen, und wir sind Attacker, na
das wird witzig, hast du schon das mit der Level 60 Sniper gesehen, du meinst die One-Hit
Sniper oder was, oder wie, oder die Sniper, wo man theoretisch Fahrzeuge mit beschädigen
können sollte, oder was meinst du, oh guck mal die Rakete, die hab ich noch nie gesehen,
schön, dass ihr mir das Intro zeigt, macht brutal Vehicle Damage, Moin Powerlocker, jawoll,
jetzt wird reingeflogen hier, jetzt hätte ich das Spawn-Beacon mitnehmen sollen, Alter
der Dude wills wissen, nein, Game, Game, ja, wa, nein ich hab das überhaupt nicht gedrückt,
du meinst Champ, sehr gut, jetzt wisst ihr natürlich, dass ich da bin, was ziemlich
zätge ist, zätge, Alter wenn man das ein bisschen kontrollieren kann, dann macht es
ja direkt Bock, man kann das halt nicht kontrollieren, ok, nice, erkennt man die Bots, ja da steht
eher einer vor, man erkennt die Bots, bist du Max FPS, korrekt, nein, fake, lull, weggebummst,
na Moment, ich soll mal, guck mal was haben wir da, ah, ein 30mm Geschütz, sehr gut,
ne, das ist ein 50mm Geschütz, oder, ne, 30, bam, suche Gegner, ah, Dozer, oh, ich
seh nix, Siege, nice, würdest du das Game noch empfehlen, nein, wie gesagt, ich empfehle
das Game echt niemand gerade, wirklich nicht, beim besten würde ich nicht, ok, vielleicht,
vielleicht haben wir Glück, ich kann hier hoch, irgendwie, irgendwie, jawoll, Massive,
Realismus pur hier, jetzt gehts ab, Massive Hyperrealism, passt wie ein Armor, was macht
der da eigentlich, ey, ich bin so dumm, ich hab, ich hab den, ah, vergessen, ich hab den
vergessen, den Dude, ich hab den nur noch unten gesehen, richtig dumm, lull, Boomer,
schon spät, Leute, schon spät, vielleicht jetzt ein Hovercraft oder so trocken, nein,
ist nicht da, schon spät, ja, Ranger aber schnell, komm, auf Ranger, gib ihm, Ranger
stells, Ranger stells, lull, Sturmgewehre, lull, habt ihr gesehen, habt ihr gesehen,
wie viele Hits der braucht, Sturmgewehre, Omega, lull, Hyper, Omega, lull, was Call of
Duty hat auch nichts gerissen dieses Jahr, kann ich nicht beurteilen, Leute, keine Ahnung,
wie ist, wie ist Vanguard so, ich hab nicht vor mir es zu kaufen, ehrlich gesagt, aber
wie ist so, ich hab ganz unterschiedliche Sachen gehört, ich hab Leute gehört, die
sagen, endlich mal wieder ein geiles Call of Duty seit Jahren, ich hab auch genug Leute
gehört, die gesagt haben, sucked, you're moving off the map, ja, sehr realistischer
Funkspruch, hä, ich dachte, trenn mal raus, richtiger Müll ist das, okay, hm, ich hab
keine Ahnung, ich glaub's euch, Leute, ich glaub's euch sofort, dass das richtiger Müll
ist, ist das der Shotgun, ey, das ist der Shot, das ist der Shotgun Tank, oder ist das
überhaupt ne Shotgun, hat, hat irgendjemand nen Plan, was das hier ist, das ist ne Shotgun,
ja, so, so, so, so, so Kanister-Shell oder sowas, das macht aber kein Damage, das macht
überhaupt kein Damage für ne Shotgun, man, also, das ist auch so ein undurchdachtes Ding,
was genau, was genau soll diese Waffe machen, was ist eigentlich deine Meinung zu BF4, 1
von 5, ähm, BF4 find ich nice, hä, was ist das, das ist ja das most useless Attachment,
was ich jemals an nem Tank gesehen hab, was ist das, damit kann ich meine Katze streicheln,
ja, übrigens könnt ihr euch dran erinnern, in Battlefield 1, ab wann ging das los, oder
war das sogar schon in 4, wo man hier normal hochklettern konnte an den Wänden, was man
jetzt gestrichen hat, Spiel, alter, das war Battlefield 1, aber in Battlefield 5 ging
das auch, oder, das ist ne Shotgun, ja, aber das ist ne Tank-Shotgun, Kanister-Shell ging
bisher immer über Range, ok, ok, Leute, vielleicht können wir jetzt mp9 spielen, ich will endlich
mal mp9 spielen, aber nein, ich darf keine mp9 spielen, weil ppega 29 halt Meta ist,
ah, get fucked up in the ass over here, vielleicht krieg ich nen Rats, das wäre richtig massive,
wenn ich nen Rats kriege, weil ich mein, ich lick, nein, eben weggesprayt, ok, ich würd
sagen, es wird Zeit, Leute, es wird Zeit, wenn man gewinnen will, muss man auch die
passende Waffe dafür spielen, das hier ist aber auch schwer, ich find das ist schon richtig
schwer und das hier ist unschaffbar im Attacker, ok, das war ppega, geb ich zu, aber vielleicht
krieg ich nen Rats, das wär sehr schön, sehr schön, Leute, wenn ihr mich retzen würdet,
oh, solid snack, nice, solid reingesnackt, richtig solide hier, richtig solide, äh, äh,
ich muss wieder weg, ich muss wieder weg, ja, vielleicht stellst du uns am Rand der Map
rum und dann klappt das irgendwie, mal hier so, hier so vielleicht, ja, das ist so, es
ist so gute Deckung, es ist so gute Deckung hier, da möchte man, da möchte man einfach
ne ganze Weile sitzen und hier eine Runde, eine Runde Pepo Comfy machen, wo hab ich
den passenden Emote, also die Deckungen sind schon richtig, richtig gut, tja, was machen
wir denn jetzt, ich hör hier unten ist doch noch was man, oder, ich hab hier was gehört
noch, oh, da ist noch mehr, wusste ich doch, da kommen noch mehr jetzt, haben wir's jetzt,
oh, der fuckt sich jetzt ab, ey, reingeflogen und Bollens Gesicht aus dem Flug, man, damit
hat er nicht gerechnet, es wäre ja schon geholfen, wenn man nicht hier lang rennen müsste, sondern,
sondern hier lang laufen dürfte, weißt du was, ich geh da jetzt rein und fuck den Typ
ab, so, ist mir egal ob ich sterbe, ich fuck jetzt den Typ hier noch ab, so easy, jetzt
kann ich sterben, das hat sich gelohnt, das ist mir egal, kommst du hier nicht runter,
oh, wir haben Hovercraft an A, Pog, Pog, Pog, oh, das ist noch Hovercraft, noch eins, noch
eins, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ach shit, toxic, warum ist das toxic, also wenn was
toxic ist dann das Mapdesign, oder, nice, was muss ich für ein Shoutout in deinen nächsten
Videos, Tier 3 Subkapper, ne, selbst Tier 3 Subkapper, du musst mir, also Shoutouts ist
ja quasi Werbung, oder musst du mir quasi das bieten, was mir EA geboten hat, dass ich
dieses Spiel bewerbe, und du kannst dir vorstellen, das war nicht billig, wobei doch, das war billiger
als es hätte sein muss, weil ich dachte zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt ja noch, das Spiel
wird gut, Max, ich hol dich, ach, wir haben gutes Wetter,
oh, PP-Guard, richtig, PP-Guard, ich gebe mir auch überhaupt keine Mühe mehr gerade,
da kannst du dich mitteilen, ne, wahrscheinlich nicht, richtig schwer, PP-Guard, stay back,
und nach der Runde ist Schluss, da gucken wir noch ein bisschen Kram, zu dem Game, und
wie sich die anderen Leute aufregen, eigentlich wollte ich zurück, weil da oben war noch was
gerade, zur anderen Seite, wenn ich zurückgehe, werden wir sterben, weil es drüben keiner
captured, ich muss zurück, ich muss zurück, da oben geht es ab, oh ja, der PP-Guard ist
am Start, ah, nice, schön, schön, dass ich von irgendwo sonst wo, nein, du hast mich doch
nicht gesehen, Mann, Overtime, ja, sehr gut, sehr gut, Overtime, Overtime, beste, alles
gut, Overtime, Overtime, gib mir, Overtime, ich fliege da jetzt rein und capture Leute,
jetzt, jetzt, Achtung, nein, ich darf noch nicht mal starten, alles klar, na gut, Max
spielt Fifa, nein, ich spiele kein Fifa, wie kommt es darauf, dass ich Fifa spiele,
ich bin, hä, wie kommt, oh, nein, ich habe es wieder nicht mitgekriegt, oh, nice, nice,
nice, lass mich rein, lass mich rein, Gachibas, lass mich rein, jetzt wird gecaptured, Mann,
that's a huge capture, wir kriegen es, ich fasse es nicht, Leute, wir kriegen es, aber
wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was das Schlimmste ist, die nächste Base ist nicht, ist nicht einnehmbar,
oh, von hinten kommt was, Gachibas, der will den Mann, Bob is, so, weiter, nächste, wo
ist er, ok, jetzt kriege ich es jetzt, jetzt kriege ich es, jetzt kriege ich es gut ab,
jetzt kriege ich es gut ab, haben wir es, ok, jetzt müssen wir schnell sein, wir müssen,
wir haben einen Angriff, wir haben eine Möglichkeit, den Kram einzunehmen, man darf nicht, also,
man, scheiß auf das unten, man muss mit allen Mann direkt aufs Dach, bevor die Typen auf
dem Dach alle hoch sind und gespawnt sind, wenn die schlau sind, spawnen die halt alle
hier oben schon direkt, aber man hat einen Angriff, um das hinzubekommen, einen Attack
hat man, aber ist das einfach durchgeflogen, gerade wieder, einen Attack haben wir, hallo,
Wingsuit, wenn du gewinnst, sag ich, das kannst du nicht gewinnen, das geht nicht,
das ist eigentlich not winnable, not stonks sozusagen, echt hat der Lost es schonmal
verloren, glaube ich nicht, und außerdem lag es bestimmt nicht an ihm, wie, warum, weil
der Lost ziemlich gut in Battlefield ist, und wenn die die Runde verlieren, liegt das
wahrscheinlich nicht an ihm, oh, das sind zu viele Mann, das wäre so ein Gachibus gewesen,
aber von der Seite, von der Seite weggeklatscht, das wäre der krass Gachibus aller Zeiten
gewesen, in dem Spiel, aber gibt's nicht, ja gut, dann warte ich jetzt bis wir B2 gecaptured
haben, dass ich unten spawnen kann, ich warte jetzt bis er eingenommen ist, hoffentlich,
hoffentlich wird er eingenommen, und dann spielen wir schöne mp9, nee die Granaten
sind zu gut, jetzt ist eh vorbei, also, wir hätten ja eine Chance gehabt das einzunehmen,
der lebt noch, glaube ich zumindest, ich glaube der lebt noch, der Dude da hinten, Mann, fuck,
ok das hat er wenigstens geschickt gemacht, da kann ich mich jetzt nicht über das Game
aufregen, Rez, Rez, Rez, Rez, Rez, Rez, Rez, Pock, danke für den Bits, 50 Billionen, ich
sehe es jetzt nicht genauer, gutes Riff, ja, alles, schön wenn es dir gefallen hat, Achtung,
Big Brainate, Big Brainate, komm mal, er hat gehittert, Big Brainate, wieder, Small Brain,
not Big Brain, Alter, ist ja gut, Mann, ok, da wäre ich auch beim Daily Scrum von DICE
gerne dabei gewesen, wer sich hier überlegt hat, dass das eine gute Idee ist, oh wir haben
sogar was gekillt, ja, sehr gute Idee, sehr gute Idee, also ich gehe da jetzt hoch, aber,
guck mal, ich meine, ich mache wahrscheinlich mehr Damage und mehr Kills, wenn ich einfach
hier unten stehe und spam Kanan rein, hä, wo kommt denn der jetzt her, oh guck mal, nice,
oh jetzt habe ich auf, jetzt habe ich, jetzt habe ich released, das war dumm, push, push,
push, Noobs in Backside, alles klar, nee, das hat mit Noobs nichts zu tun, das ist einfach
nicht, nicht, nicht einnehmbar, Achtung, check, es ist übrigens auch ganz wichtig, dass bei
so einem fucking OP Spot, die Defender auch noch den Heli haben, scheint mir ganz wichtig
für die Balance zu sein, warum man nicht einnehmen kann, naja, weil die, weil das zu klein ist,
also wo man hochkommt, also das geht nicht, not enough space to deploy, warum, ah, ich
hab dir gesehen, wie schnell die Leute wegfahren, die aimen halt einfach alles ab und du kannst
halt auch easy alles ab aimen, das ist einfach nur richtig maximal dumm, was man sich dabei
gedacht hat, das ist so, das ist, das ist unglaublich dumm und hängen geblieben, was anderes fällt
mir echt nicht mehr ein, ja, klar, klar, klar, natürlich, da war es einfach am Metro, also
im Metro konnte man ja noch irgendwie einnehmen, ich müsste fließen zwischen Webster und der
hier wechseln können, dass du irgendwie eine Chance hast, Halbfigster irgendwo sinnvoll
hinzukommen, ein Problem, PP29, das ist richtig, hast du Probleme, nimm einfach die PP29,
das ist kein Problem mehr, was, ok, YOLO, YOLO, die aimen schon ab, ich sag euch, ich
predicte Leute, die aimen mich schon ab, bevor ich richtig oben bin, ok, links, rechts, links,
rechts, ich geh links, ich geh links, ich geh links, guck hier, die aimen mich schon
ab, und tschüss, und wieder hoch, und rechts, und rechts, und rechts, und rechts.
Also was anderes fällt mir gar nicht ein, wie macht man den Winx und wieder zu einfach
her, also C drücken, oder E, E oder C, ich mach das schon automatisch, top C, richtig
gutes Design, sehr gut, sehr gut, das ganze Team müsste von allen Seiten kommen, dann
geht das, also ich will nicht bestreiten, dass wenn man es wirklich auf die Sekunde genau
koordiniert und ein richtig gutes Team hat gegen vielleicht nicht ganz so gute Gegner,
dass es vielleicht funktioniert, hat übrigens Kommentare in meinem Video erklären, wie das
einfach geht, ich hab nen Comment gelesen, der erklärt, wie man das ganz einfach einnimmt,
einfach Luftunterstützung anfordern, einfach einen Heli anfordern, der das Dach cleart,
das steht genauso in den Kommentaren unter meinem Video, einfach einen Heli anfordern,
der das Dach cleart, sollte doch eigentlich jedem einleuchten, just Heli anfordern und
das Dach clearn, easy, kein Problem, ich bin interessiert was der Lost dazu sagt, der hat
sich ja ein bisschen bedeckt gehalten in den letzten Tagen, ich würd mich echt mal interessieren
was er sagt, kucken wir uns das nochmal an, was sagt er denn, der Cluster, ja, ja sag
ich ja, siehst du ein, sehen dich 5, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja ich mein sei denn fast alles anoin, dass ist auch ein groser
Ich krieg mal bessere Reaction. Ich mein, ich mit meinen Boomer 37, ich hab sicherlich nicht mal das geilste, die geilsten Reactions oder sonst was.
Aber trotzdem, zeig mir irgendeinen, du kannst ein Team machen aus irgendwie den ultra krassen Pros, die reacten auch nicht 4 vs 128 alles weg.
Wie soll denn das überhaupt funktionieren, wenn du die Gegner nicht um was siehst? Du kannst ja schlecht auf was reagieren, was du nicht siehst.
Also er hat voll und ganz recht, also die Leute, die das nicht verstehen wollen, versteh ich nicht.
Das war du einfach von der Masse an Leuten, die vor dir stehen jetzt, die du teilweise mal 2 nehmen kannst im Durchschnitt im Vergleich zu den Teilen davor, weil es ja auch die toppe der Anzahl an Spielern ist.
Das heißt, du musst nicht 2-3 Leute, die auf einmal vor dir aufploppen, versuchen zu killen, sondern es sind 5+, die dich am Schluss töten, auch wenn du 3 wegbekommst, weil der Rest, wenn er nicht gerade Pepega ist, dich ja killen kann.
Oder die Leute, die mit dem Sniper rein aimen, mit der DMR rein aimen oder von der Seite gerade reinspornen oder reinlaufen, die dich halt dann killen.
Ja, so ist es. Das ist für einen, so blöd sich das anhört, für einen guten Spieler irgendwann ein bisschen frustrierend, weil er merkt, dass er selbst mit seinen Fähigkeiten nicht dagegen ankommt.
Ja. Was noch ein Punkt ist, der dazu... Und es ist ja auch nicht so, als könntest du sagen, ich übe das jetzt richtig krass. Da gibt's eigentlich nix zu üben.
Emily, Smile, Zorras, danke ihr beiden für den Sub.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber ich finde, das war zu einem Teil in Call of Duty eh schon eine ganze Weile so und das war in Battlefield auch so, aber nicht so extrem.
Ja gut, Chet, klar, die sind auch frustriert, wenn sie keinen Fuß auf den Boden kriegen, aber die haben andere Ansprüche.
Die haben die Ansprüche, mal zehn Minuten in Richtung der Gegner zu sprayen und dann halt zwei Kills zu machen, dann sind die happy.
Ich hatte auf der Arbeit, jetzt kommt Boomer, sorry, aber er ist noch nicht so lange her.
Ich hatte vor bis ungefähr einem Jahr, der ist noch ein bisschen älter, wahrscheinlich würde ich sagen so 40 ein Kollege auf der Arbeit, der hat Fortnite gespielt. Der hat einen Sohn, der hat Fortnite gespielt und der Vater hat dann auch Fortnite gespielt.
Und da war das noch neu, also schon zwei Jahre oder drei Jahre her, da war das noch relativ neu und der hat nie gewonnen und hatte trotzdem ultra Spaß an diesem Game, weil der immer eins, zwei Leute gekillt hat.
Und irgendwann ist der morgens, kein Scheiß, der ist morgens zu mir gekommen, ich muss dir was erzählen, ich habe gestern eine Runde Fortnite gewonnen.
Ich lag und das ist jetzt kein Witz, der hat gesagt, er hat erzählt, ich lag einfach rum und die anderen haben sich beschossen und am Ende war ich der Letzte, der übrig war.
Der hat nichts gemacht, der hat einfach nur in der Ecke gelegen und hat gewonnen und hat sich das Todes gefreut, der war mega happy.
Also da sieht man, die Ansprüche von so den ultra casual Spielern sind auch viel niedriger.
Dementsprechend muss das Game sowas einbauen, dass die einfach mal random Mice in die Gegner sprayen können und einmal einen Kill kriegen, dann ist für den die Woche gerettet.
Der lockt sich abends ein, spielt eine halbe Stunde und davon macht der eine Viertelstunde Pepega 29 Dauerfeuer in die Gegner.
Und dann macht er zwei Kills und dann legt er sich abends hin und denkt sich, das war mal richtig schön, richtig schöne Runde gezockt, so war das geil und dann pennt er und ist happy.
So, dafür ist das gemacht.
Mokochan, Dankeschön, ich weiß, dass ich nicht ultra beschissen spiele, ich weiß auch, dass ich jetzt nicht super krass spiele oder so.
Es ist durchaus in Ordnung finde ich.
Mit der MP, die ist schon ein bisschen genauer, vor allem die Pepega 29, deswegen spielt die auch gerade da.
Pepega 29, jetzt fängt er auch schon an, jetzt fängt er auch schon an.
Leute, ich habe echt, ich glaube echt, wir haben das etabliert hier. Ich habe das in meinem Video gesagt vor zwei Tagen, da hat es noch niemand benutzt und hier im Chat auch.
Und jetzt fangen sie alle an.
Wenn zwei sich beschießen und entschieden wird, wer gewinnt. Was aber daraus resultiert ist, dass der weitaus schlechtere Spieler halt auch mal Leute weghauen kann, die halt besser sind, wenn sie jetzt nicht gerade in der Pepega 29 sind.
Ihr wisst aber, was ich meine. Schlechtere Spieler werden mehr belohnt, weil der eigentliche Skill nicht mehr diese Wertigkeit hat, wie es vor allem in den Teilen davor war.
Sachen wie Recoil Control oder was auch immer.
Das wichtigste, ich sage euch jetzt mal, was für mich in Battlefield das mit Abstand wichtigste ist, um gut zu spielen.
Das ist auch ein bisschen Spielertyp abhängig.
Okay, das wichtigste ist Position in Battlefield für mich.
Wenn du mit Hirn spielst und die Gegner outmoves, musst du sie nicht outamen.
Ich kann sicherlich so die richtig krassen jungen Flick Twitch-Amer nicht mehr outamen.
Aber ich kann mit Hirn spielen und sag mal mal 90% der Gegner outplayen.
Und das funktioniert nicht mit 128 Spieler und dem Randomness, wie dieses Game hat.
Das ist mein eigentliches Problem.
Du hast eine gute Idee, gut ausgeführt, wirst aber richtig weggefickt von der Seite.
Über was du nichts kannst, weil du kannst einfach nicht ohne Information predikten, wo der jetzt ist.
Man muss auch mal dazu sagen, es wird uns immer erzählt, dass das in Battlefield 2 davor auch der Fall war.
Unter anderem, weil viele Leute im Portal das z.B. mit Battlefield Bad Company verglichen haben.
Und dann gesagt wurde, dass Battlefield Bad Company teilweise auch so eine Streuung hat.
Jaja, die Leute sind blöd.
Also ganz ehrlich, wer in Portal geht, Bad Company 2 anschmeißt, sieht, dass die Waffen streuen und darauf schließt,
dass Bad Company 2 ernsthaft auch so eine Streuung gehabt hat.
Die sind einfach hängen geblieben.
Das Schwachsinn, Bad Company 2 hatte nie im Leben so eine Streuung.
Bad Company 2 hat dich belohnt, wenn du Single-Schuss machst.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Aber auch mit der Saw musstest du quasi...
In Bad Company 2 hast du mit der Saw so geschossen.
Guck, mit der Saw hast du so geschossen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das jetzt zeigen kann.
Mit der Saw hast du so geschossen.
Hast du immer so runtergezogen dabei.
Und bist permanent auf dem Gegner dadurch geblieben.
Und das ist hier nicht möglich in dem Game.
Und das haben auch schon viele gemacht, denn die Leute sind danach in Bad Company 2 reingenommen.
Ups, warum habe ich hier...
Das Game gibt es noch.
Du kannst das offizielle, originale Bad Company 2 noch online spielen.
Die Leute sind reingegangen, haben die gleiche Waffe genommen, das gleiche Setup.
Haben das getestet.
Oh, den hat er dann alles gebäscht.
Und gleich natürlich sagen können, ne, stimmt nicht.
Die Ungenauigkeit der Waffen ist im Original Bad Company.
Ist nicht so.
Nö, nö.
Bad Company Waffen im Portal oder so ist.
Gar nicht.
Du brauchst gefühlt zwei Magazine, wenn du auf den Typen reinschießt.
Selbst wenn du einen Burst machst.
Das sind alles Sachen, die dafür sprechen, dass die schlechteren Spieler...
Und das ist ganz böse gemeint, ne?
Naja, ein bisschen schon.
Aber ich gebe ihm ja recht.
Das ist halt, entweder ist es marketingtechnisch extra so gedacht.
Ist es.
Um halt auch den...
Habe ich auch schon oft gesagt.
128 Spieler ist hauptsächlich Marketinggeschiss gewesen.
Alle Castle-Spieler anzusprechen.
Das ist, um zu sagen, größer, besser, latest, greatest, Battlefield.
Dafür ist es gedacht.
Spielerisch hat das...
Das ist für Arsch.
Hey krass, ich kann jetzt kills machen.
Holy shit, Alter.
Das kann man nur vermuten, das kann man nur in Frage stellen.
Aber...
Fakt ist, dass diese Mechaniken aktuell dazu führen, dass es so ist.
Und das ist für einen Spieler, der halt länger Shooter schon spielt.
Okay, ich muss zugeben, dass jetzt...
Ich gebe ihm recht.
Man hätte das aber besser verargumentieren können.
Ich meine zu sagen, es ist so, es ist fucked, dass es so ist.
Ist vielleicht nicht die beste Begründung.
Aber es ist so.
Der Bad Company 2 hat im Leben nicht diese Streuung gehabt, wie es hier im Portal hat.
Übrigst frustrierend.
Hier ist übrigens der Cluster, gegen den du in dem Moment nichts machen kannst.
Deine Fähigkeiten limitiert werden durch Einstellungen, die das Spiel hat.
Das Spiel sagt einfach nein.
Das ist halt der Punkt.
Da muss auf jeden Fall was passieren.
Ach, übrigens.
Das mit diesen 128 Spieler, das wird ja auch gerne als Ausrede verwendet.
Ja, das Spiel ist technisch so krass und hat 128 Spieler.
Es gibt einen Mod für Battlefield 3.
Wenn du da einen fetten Server hattest, mit fetter Single-Core-CPU,
kannst du auch 127 Spieler spielen.
Und das lief.
Und das war nicht hier Slow-Motion.
Also das ist jetzt nicht hier Raketentechnologie mit 128 Spieler.
Klar, die Interaktion ist in diesem Spiel ein bisschen größer.
Aber das ist wie gesagt jetzt kein Teufelszeug oder so.
Die jetzt schon zumindest über Twitter gesagt, dass sie Sachen auf dem Schirm haben und anpassen werden.
Aber man muss auf jeden Fall aufpassen.
Wir müssen als Spieler aufpassen, dass wir uns natürlich nicht mit diversen Sachen abspeisen lassen.
Richtig.
Der sagt in jedem Shooter gehören für mich Recoil-Patterns rein.
Das heißt, dass du...
Das finde ich nicht.
Das muss nicht sein.
Es würde ja schon reichen, wenn das Waffenhandling halbwegs normal ist.
...festgelegte Movements hast.
Das braucht man nicht unbedingt.
Bin ich.
Kann man sich drüber streiten.
Wir kennen das aus Godot Counter-Strike, wo du ein umgedrehtes L schießen musst,
bei der M4 oder so.
Und am Schluss halt im Spray, wir reden von Sprayen, halt relativ punktgenau in Anführungsstrichen schießen zu können.
Natürlich ist immer ein gewisser Spread, aber der ist halt dann nicht so,
sondern der ist halt dann auf einem Punkt, right?
Alles klar.
Und ich bin jemand, der das seit darin erzählt.
Warum Shooter nicht einfach festgelegte Recoil-Patterns rein machen,
weil dann ist es nämlich gleiches Recht für alle.
Jeder hat die Möglichkeit, abhängig davon natürlich wie viel Zeit...
Nee, gleiches Recht für alle darf doch nicht sein.
Wie sollen die das Gamenet verkaufen dann?
Aber jeder hat die Möglichkeit, sich eine Waffe auszusuchen, zu sagen, die mag ich,
und die zu trainieren und zu lernen.
Weil jeder hat am Schluss die gleichen Voraussetzungen.
Ja, das stimmt schon, aber das geht auch ohne Recoil-Pattern.
Also ich bin eigentlich nicht so der Freund von 100% Recoil.
Ich finde, das Handling der Waffe sollte eben anständig sein.
Man sollte nicht krass einen zusätzlichen Random-Faktor machen,
sodass es ab dem fünften Schuss gar nichts mehr trifft.
Aber ich finde, die richtig 100% Recoil-Pattern wie beispielsweise in CS,
das brauchst du eigentlich nicht.
Es wird ja schon reichen, wenn man es nicht noch schlimmer macht.
Du hast eine Waffe, die du, wenn du die sprayen willst, auf die Entfernung,
was meistens in Shootern der Fall ist, gerade mit Assault Rifles oder so,
außer du schießt halt über 200 Meter und dann musst du halt Einzelfeuer machen
oder einfach einen Sniper nehmen, dass du halt, um das zu erreichen
und nicht ppegermäßig komplett die Tauben oben wegzuschießen
oder irgendwo hinzusprayen, musst du die Waffe halt lernen.
Und das kostet halt Zeit, aber das bietet ja auch einen langfristigen Spielspaß,
weil du merkst, wie besser du wirst, wie du besser bist mit der Waffe.
Und das bietet halt einfach...
Also ich finde, es hat schon gereicht, wenn es so ist wie in Battlefield 3.
Dazu so was wie eine M16 oder eine AEK. Die AEK hat ja auch irgendwie den da gemacht.
Da hast du halt ein bisschen dagegen gezogen.
Die M4 hat einen großen Kick und ging dann eigentlich
mehr oder weniger Stride hoch und sowas.
Ich finde, das reicht. Das muss nicht 100%ig irgendwie
super genau sein auf 100%ig oder so.
Also ordentliches, ordentliches...
Also es ist ja ein Unterschied zwischen Recoil Pattern und Recoil.
Recoil ist ja quasi, wenn die Waffe hochzieht.
Recoil Pattern ist, dass es so ist wie in CS, dass es nicht dorthin schießt,
wo du hinzielst, es sei denn, du zielst dorthin mit dem Fadenkreuz,
wo du dann nicht hinschießt, weil du weißt, das Recoil geht jetzt dahin.
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine? In CS ist es ja so, wenn du in CS mit der AK spielst,
dann ist das Fadenkreuz in der Mitte, aber du schießt, aber du musst es dann...
Wie ging das CS nochmal? Irgendwie so runterziehen oder so?
Und dann irgendwie hin und her, ne? Irgendwie so schräg runter
und dann hin und her mit der AK. Ich kriege das immer hin.
Aber du zielst dann nicht dorthin mit dem Fadenkreuz, wo du wirklich hinschießt,
aber du weißt, wo der Recoil hingeht. Das ist ja da unten natürlich
ein Recoil Pattern. Moment, ich zeige euch das.
CS AK Recoil Pattern. Du verstehst nichts.
Spray Pattern, ok. Ok, Achtung. Achtung.
Ok, ok. Guckt es euch an. Ihr seht, das Fadenkreuz ist da,
die Schüsse gehen dahin. So, das heißt, was musst du jetzt machen,
wenn du willst, dass es in der Mitte steht, du musst dein Fadenkreuz...
Also wenn du willst, dass der Schuss hier bleibt, musst du dein Fadenkreuz dahin ziehen.
Guckt. Der zeigt es gleich.
Da hin. Nee, da hin.
Der Mitte-State, ja. Guckt, seht ihr? Seht ihr?
Das meine ich. Er schießt dahin, sein Fadenkreuz ist da.
Nee, das Fadenkreuz soll sich nicht bewegen. Du musst das Fadenkreuz bewegen,
aber du schießt halt nicht dorthin, wo das Fadenkreuz ist.
Recoil ist einfach nur bewegen, das Fadenkreuz nach oben,
und du kannst runterziehen, und du bist immer dort drauf,
wo dein Fadenkreuz ist. In Battlefield schießt die Waffe außer random Faktor.
In Battlefield schießt die Waffe dorthin, wo dein Fadenkreuz ist.
Das heißt, in Battlefield ziehst du einfach nur runter
und behältst das Fadenkreuz auf dem Target.
In CS ist das anders. In CS ist dein Target hier.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das Fadenkreuz richtig erkennt.
In CS ist dein Target hier, und ihr seht doch, guckt mal,
der schießt dahin, guckt mal, wo der mit dem Fadenkreuz ist.
Der schießt hier hin, und sein Fadenkreuz ist da unten.
Deswegen, ich finde, das muss in Battlefield nicht sein.
Das ist halt das, was du bei Recoil-Pattern hast.
Guck mal, der schießt da unten, das Fadenkreuz ist da,
und da schießt er hin.
In Battlefield ist es halt so, du stayst auf Target,
geiler Satz, ich weiß, und solltest dann dahin schießen,
solange du in der Lage bist, die Waffe runterzuziehen,
dass dein Ziel im Target bleibt. Das ist halt der Unterschied.
Das ist nicht richtig scheiße, das ist in CS mindestens
die Hälfte des Skills, das Spray- und Waffenhandling.
Umso höher man kommt, umso weniger.
Ich glaube, der Lost möchte nicht, dass das so ist wie in CS.
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, was er meint.
Das ist wie in CS, glaube ich nicht.
Deswegen sage ich ja, ich mag den Recoil, wie er in Battlefield 3, 4 und so ist,
aber ich will nicht Recoil-Pattern wie in CS haben.
Und das ist meines Erachtens für jedes Game da draußen nur positiv.
Klar wirst du ein paar Stimmen haben von den absoluten,
den absoluten Casual-Playern am unteren Ende,
und das ist wie gesagt nicht böse gemeint,
aber die sich halt denken, naja, aber ich will keinen Effort reinlegen,
ich will einfach stupide ballern.
Ja gut, aber dann kann ich dir unter anderem ganz viele Shooter nennen,
die das mittlerweile ja anbieten.
Wie wär's mit Battlefield 5, Battlefield 1?
Ich meine, du konntest in allen Battlefields stupide ballern,
hier jetzt halt noch etwas stupider, nur mit noch weniger Nachvollziehbarkeit dahinter, leider.
Das ist es, da hat er recht.
Das ist nichts, lass mich raten, Lost sagt jetzt sowas wie,
das ist nicht Timmy aus der Nachbarschaft oder irgendwie sowas.
Das ist auch bei Battlefield, wer ist denn die Zielgruppe, die langfristig...
Irgendwie sowas kommt da jetzt.
Ich, ich, ich, ich, ich predicte es schon mal.
Okay Bernd, Bernd, nicht Timmy aus der Nachbarschaft,
es ist Casual Bernd in dem Fall, alles klar.
... mein Shooter ausprobiert, oder es ist es auch nicht Casual Tim Thumb,
der sich denkt, oh ich spiel jetzt ab und zu mal ein bisschen hier neben...
Ich wusste, dass sowas kommt.
... weil ich dort auch was reißen kann.
Das sind die Battlefield-Fans, das sind die Battlefield-Fans,
die Hardcore-Battlefield-Spieler, wenn man es mal so nennen möchte,
die halt die Teile davor gespielt haben,
die teilweise jetzt auch noch auf Battlefield 4, Battlefield Bad Company,
von mir aus sogar auch Hardline, holy shit, hängen geblieben sind.
Und diese Spiele teilweise, obwohl die vor acht Jahren rausgekommen sind,
immer noch aktiv auf den Servern, die noch laufen, spielen.
Das stimmt.
Diese Zielgruppe musst du doch am Schluss tangieren.
Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Und diese Zielgruppe ist aktuell...
Ja, sehe ich ganz genau so.
... und dem auch, was ich so mitbekommen habe und auch lesen kann und hören kann
da draußen...
Nee, finde ich, dass er übertreibt.
Der hat schon recht.
Guckt mal, wer heute dem Spiel die Treue hält.
Das sind die Leute, die einfach...
Die Hardcore-Battlefield-Fans, das sind die,
die sie ausgenommen haben mit ihrer Nostalgie-Werbung.
Und da bin ich ihnen wirklich böse drum.
Und das ja auch kritisieren aktuell, was hier in 2042 geändert wurde,
auch teilweise im Vergleich zu Battlefield 5,
was ich persönlich auch nicht nachvollziehen kann,
weil das Game ja eigentlich auf BF5 krass basiert.
Und ich hab's letztens schon mal genannt,
Battlefield 5, einer der, der Battlefield Teil war, zuletzt der letzte,
den ja viele nicht so gefeiert haben.
Das stimmt, ich auch nicht.
Aber der trotzdem bei den Sachen gut gemacht hat, die ich mir auch hier gewünscht...
Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn ich Battlefield 2042 jetzt sehe,
hätt ich mir gewünscht, doch mehr Battlefield 5 zu spielen.
Weil, also, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es schlechter werden kann.
Und auch davon ausgegangen bin tatsächlich, dass die so drin sind,
weil es komplett Sinn macht und halt auch wirklich was Gutes war.
Movement-Geschichten oder auch das Mapping-Handling.
Das war jetzt auch nicht perfekt, da gab's auch auf die gewisse Entfernung,
gab's da auch Streuungen und so, aber die waren nicht ansatzweise so stark wie hier.
Das kann ich nicht so sagen, ich hab das zu wenig gespielt.
Wenn du dahin geschossen hast, wo du hinschießen wolltest.
Und das ist auf jeden Fall ein Punkt, den müssen wir im Kopf behalten.
Auf, gib ihm, gib ihm, los, mach ihn platt.
Das wären sie sich wahrscheinlich auch zu...
Gib ihm, gib ihm.
Bam!
...hoffentlich, da war Gott sei Dank jetzt auch mal...
Schreckt!
...da drin, holy shit, let's go.
Das ist auch ein Punkt, wo ich auch hinterstehe, ganz klar.
Fakt ist, mir macht das Game Spaß, auf jeden Fall.
Mir macht das echt Spaß.
Okay, das muss ich jetzt auch mal was zu sagen.
Ja, das Game hat seine Momente.
Aber mittlerweile muss ich sagen, der Aufrege zu Spaß...
Die Aufrege zu Spaß Ratio ist bei mir mittlerweile zu verschoben.
Deswegen war das heute wahrscheinlich auch der letzte Tag.
...und die Leute mal headshotted, die Leute auch weglasern und so.
Und du musst dich auf gewisse Gegebenheiten einfach komplett einstellen und auch umstellen.
Wie du dich bewegst, wie du moves, wie du agierst, wie du deinen Playstyle...
Okay, du musst Fiveheads sein, möchte er sagen.
Das ist okay, das kann ich schon machen.
Aber für mich persönlich ist diese Umstellung oder diese Anpassung, in Anführungsstrichen,
auch ein Stück weit begrenzt.
Gerade was zeitliche Aspekte angehen.
Soll heißen...
Ja, okay, ich glaube, ich habe deine Aussage verstanden.
Ja, gäbe ich ihm im Kurs da wirklich komplett recht.
Zeig mal, wie sieht denn die Metakritik aus?
Ist es noch ein schlechter geworden?
Steam?
Gucken wir mal, Steam?
Ah, Moment, Moment.
Die obligatorische... wie sieht es mit New World aus?
Okay, immer noch schlecht.
Es ist so fail, Alter.
Easy.
Äh, okay.
Steam, Battlefield 2042.
Okay, ist immer noch richtig, richtig gut, wie es aussieht.
26% sind positiv.
Hey, das ist 1% mehr als gestern.
Gestern waren es, glaube ich, 25%.
1% mehr positiv.
Pock, es geht aufwärts, Leute.
Okay.
Puma, Bett, müde, schon spät.
Wupp.
Bettge.
Übrigens, Leute, ich muss jetzt mal eine Sache loswerden.
Schön, dass die letzten Tage, auch wenn ich mich ein bisschen über das Spiel aufgeregt habe,
so viele Leute eingeschaltet haben.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat, ich mache normalerweise, ehrlich gesagt,
eigentlich weniger Battlefield und Gaming.
Ich mache eigentlich fast mehr IT-Geschichten auf Twitch.
Aber trotzdem schön, dass ihr da gewesen seid.
Vielleicht ist ja, wie gesagt, vielleicht spiele ich auch noch ein paar Mal Battlefield nächster Zeit.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat, könnt ihr trotzdem gerne followen, würde mich sehr freuen.
Ihr könnt auch mal bei mir auf Twitter oder auf YouTube vorbeigucken.
Und vielleicht sehen wir uns ja da und sind bestimmt auch viele von YouTube da,
die jetzt über die Verlinkungen in den Kommentaren das hergefunden haben.
Wir hatten übrigens gestern oder vorgestern hier den ersten seit einer Weile Meilenstein wieder.
Wir haben es nämlich geschafft, 19.000 Follower auf Twitch.
Richtig massive Pock.
Also, wir sehen uns bis dann, macht's gut.
See you!